how are we doing today people it's your
boy voodoo vids in the house
and today i'm with a very special guest
none other than
allah ali thank you so much for being
here with us today
thank you for having me and uh hello to
the world
i'm also in my house
do you want to do something uh a similar
sort of uh sort of you know
greeting like yo yo yo you know it's
your boy hey it's your boy double a in
the house
noble uh it's more like triple a or oh
yeah
oh yes the you know us
i can guarantee that my backdrop is not
present in some sort of cave in
afghanistan
yeah listen he's speaking from a
unconfirmed location
somewhere in the region from morocco to
malaysia and we can't confirm where
yeah exactly exactly um
but there you go so um thank you so much
for being on man and uh thank you so
much guys for tuning in as well i
appreciate that
before we get into the conversation uh
please share this link
with your friends with your families and
extra neighbor with your cat with your
dog
maybe they can learn something from this
exchange and uh you know let's uh get
the word out there
and uh let's have a a very sort of open
and uh
you know friendly funny honest whatever
you want to call it conversation
so i said um
for those people who may not be aware um
you are a
muslim a a convert to islam um
and uh i would actually recommend
checking out assad allah's uh
youtube channel because on his youtube
channel he's got a story
a video about his story how he converted
to islam and that whole journey his life
as well
basically a short biography and i found
it very uh
very interesting very honest and open uh
raw you know and uh i feel like i've got
a better understanding of yourself and
uh you know i i thought that video was
great i mean
if you can actually post a link to that
in the chat that would be great so
people can maybe
like refer to that later uh but you're
convert to islam
and i am someone who was born muslim but
left islam so we are having a friendly
conversation without any
anyone getting hurt so i i would say
that's a good start
because you know we're separated by
computer screens
oh yes exactly separate and by the way
this guy that i'm speaking to he may
look very friendly and
cuddly but he is a master in taekwondo
so if anyone gets brave enough to
challenge him i would just say you know
at your own peril i'm old now so that's
probably not going to happen
well you know you uh what's the word you
mature with ages
it's like old wine you know the older
you get the better you get so uh you
know
um but you know thanks so much and can i
ask
how did you first uh come across
my channel and then we can get onto the
context video but i mean how
when you first saw my satire or some of
the videos what do you think about this
guy's crazy what he's doing
be as honest as as you want it was funny
and charming i never i never had any
you know issue with you or anything like
that there were you know people would
show me your videos and i would watch
them and sometimes i would laugh
and you know i'd think about what you
were saying and things and then one day
somebody kind of came along and said can
you respond to this video sorry give me
one second
i'm posting that link and they said uh
can you respond to this particular video
and i i watched your video and
then you know that was it that was it
and um how was the um this is me asking
as
a uh someone who's a satisfy as a
creator you know
a small one with a small c not the not
the creator
but a small creator in a sense how was
the process of looking at a satirical
video
that is uh talking about your religion
in a humorous way in a critical way and
then you had to
then make your own video satirical
humor and also addressing the points how
did you find that process for you
well it was normal i mean i've done this
forever
the thing is like i mean not in terms of
like satire actually i don't
recall maybe i've done one satire video
in the past but
like i'm used to it like i've been in
academia for
several years you know i'm used to
people critiqu you know critiquing my
views and vice versa
so it was not something that i wasn't
like not accustomed to or anything that
shocked me
or that i was uncomfortable with i mean
i don't i don't um
[Music]
i never had an issue with it so
that's great so um
okay so guys i i see some questions in
the comment section i will get your
questions
do not worry um as it is uh
give us some time to acquaint ourselves
and then we i'll let you guys take over
as you always do
um so um let's start with
uh something which i think is absolutely
necessary
for um people like me me and you is that
you know
we both have gone opposite directions
now i've almost seemed to have another
way
you weren't muslim you become muslim and
we and you know there are
the presence of ex-muslims is much more
visible in social media and what not
and just because you know i i'm an
ex-muslim and i see him as ex-muslim
that doesn't necessarily necessarily
mean i agree with them or that i
agree with their uh perception of islam
or the way they
talk about islam on muslims so what
would be your advice and
and i think we need engagement from both
sides my channel i really
really uh sort of value free speech and
engagement whether it's through comedy
or
these types of videos what would be your
advice
to muslims who maybe
want to reach out to sorry what would
you advise to ex-muslims
who want to reach out to ex-muslims so
i'm getting so messed up now
what would be otherwise to ex-muslims
who want to reach out to muslims
in the way they in the way they create
their dialogue in the way they speak to
people
um so for example we were talking about
this earlier before
if you hear an ex-muslim uh say i'm just
going to say and then we can talk about
later
oh mohammed was a pedophile he stopped
the nine-year-old
so how could you believe in someone like
that i mean that's disgusting bro like
what's wrong with you man come on
now i know in their minds they think
that's an
amazing argument but it doesn't come
across like that always
so what would be your advice to those
people in how to age
well you know um i i'm not one to tone
you know police tone i don't i don't
like doing that
however i will say that if you're going
to approach somebody with such a trite
attitude or with some with such trite
responses
don't expect them to think that you want
a serious conversation
you know i've had a lot of people for
instance come up to me or online at
least and
attempt to um debate quote-unquote or
have a discussion with me and you know
that's one of the first thing that comes
out of their mouth and they expect me to
respond to them
you know with some sort of sophisticated
uh
form of argument or something or you
know just you know just have a normal
talk with them it's like
i know what you're doing you know what i
mean like for me i can tell that
that you are not really interested in a
real discussion here and it's not that
i'm so much offended by
what they're saying i'm offended by the
fact that they assume
they can come in there and talk to me
and then expect me not to respond in
kind
you know what i mean like that's the
thing that i don't really understand
with a lot of people especially
not all ex-muslims but a lot of them who
kind of come into my chats or on my
facebook page and then say these like
really rude and disgusting things and
then just want me to be like
oh you know okay let's have a nice talk
and and just
share some evidences and then have some
tea and it's like i know what you're
doing you're not here to have a talk you
know you're here to just make me angry
um so uh
you know that's one thing is that if you
want to have sort of respectful dialogue
then you should show respect
if you don't you know don't do it that's
fine but don't expect
the muslims to respond nicely
to those sort of remarks um so that's
one thing
secondly i think the most important
thing is that uh
and i think we already talked about this
earlier was that
there is a huge problem in society in
general not just among ex-muslims
or muslims but in society in general in
what we call quote-unquote the
information age
you know now that we have the internet
everyone has all this information on
their hands
and uh it sort of made everyone believe
that somehow they're an expert
on everything and you know um and as
somebody who's working academia for a
long time now and i'm talking about like
seven eight years i've worked with
policy institutes think tanks
um across the world primarily malaysia
you know counter-terrorism
um studies i've also done studies on
in the environment and policy reforms
and things like this
i can tell you right now that one of the
most annoying things that i come across
in any discussion
are a bunch of people who no offense you
know work
some job okay and i'm not disrespecting
anybody's position in life
you know uh that has nothing to do with
the subject that they're discussing
they look up something for 10 minutes on
youtube or
wikipedia or something and then they and
then they want to be put on the same
level
as somebody who has worked in the field
for 10 years
okay who really knows what they're
talking about and um
there's this perception out there that
somehow there's this democracy of
knowledge
and um and that's really annoying not
only for academics but when you're
trying to have a serious sophisticated
discussion about something
and you want to show evidence and you
have somebody on the other side of the
of the panel quote-unquote who wants to
be taken seriously
and on the same level as an expert who
has done almost no research
this is a huge issue um
and you see this all the time especially
with like uh especially in debates about
islam
you know like oh islam start you know it
is the reason for terrorism in the world
today
it's like have you even bothered to like
read
one empirical study on the psychological
profiles of these terrorists
like one like i'm just not not even like
like a sentence these people have even
ever read
because i can tell i can tell when
people when they make these arguments
like oh you know they sat down one day
they read the quran and then all of a
sudden they just want to go bomb people
and it's like no that's not how it works
it's not even close
um you had some guests on on your show
earlier who keeps sort of
mentioning this this myth that you know
oh you know they they study islam the
more religious they get and then all of
a sudden they want to go kill people and
it's like
i can tell they've never even done five
minutes of study
because most the vast majority of
researchers in counter-terrorism studies
and psychologists who have actually done
case studies and profiles on these
people
would completely disagree with you you
know like
and i can i have so much evidence on
hand right now before this discussion i
like i got like 20
references on me just in the last year
you know showing that this opinion is
nonsense
okay okay i'm sorry i don't read too
much because i know no no no
that's fine it's fine it's very
interesting um sorry i can hear myself
so like for instance you know you got
some guy in your chat
yeah he said islamic scholars are
apologists not scholars i
see i'm not talking about islamic
scholars i'm talking about
secular scholars who have studied
counterterrorism
who have studied psychology i'm talking
about atheists hindus christians
jews who actually
did research i'm not talking about some
guy in saudi arabia
who studied you know akita or something
i'm talking about people who have done
research on the subject
right do you think that you weren't that
you were talking nonsense
um i think i can hear myself in your oh
really
there's a bit of echo
so i mean like i have proof for it too i
mean i could just post it right now and
like
half the people who are in your chat
wouldn't even know what's going on
because they've never even bothered to
research this stuff they think all
academic research is nonsense
or they think there's some sort of
conspiracy to protect islam from
criticism
which is nonsense as well let me see if
i put my headphones in without help
uh hello yeah yeah that's
much better much better okay so let's
start with something small
before we get into you mentioned quite a
lot and you're more than welcome to
share this on on the chat if you want
no no problem or all the uh
work the reports and whatnot let's start
with
let's say for example aim x muslim or
even forget just a person whether the
ex-muslim or non-muslim whatever you
want to call it
let's say they hear you know they do
have a problem with the age of isiah
let's just use this as a as an example
or we could be something else or
multiple wives or whatever take a pic
they have a problem with this issue how
would you want
them to come and approach you and they
have and you know and
they are concerned about this they find
this immoral or strange or
they think this is not a good model for
force for society if they count to
how would you want them to address this
issue with someone like yourself or
another muslim
to have a fruitful discussion okay well
first off
um and i say this without trying to be
rude but and i say this even to myself
when you ever go up to to discuss with
somebody these issues
like i said this is advice for myself as
well one
know your place and what i mean by that
is know what you don't know
and try to figure out what the other
person knows first before you try to
jump into a discussion with them
because for example if you're talking to
some regular guy on a facebook post or
whatever okay that's fine
right some person who has equal amount
of knowledge than you
but if you're going up against somebody
who has studied this subject for a very
long time
don't expect to go in there and
quote-unquote
them you know because that's not how
it's going to happen
all right you're probably gonna get
humiliated that's good that's gonna
that's what's gonna happen
and if your idea is to go in there and
try to humiliate this person or make
their followers leave them or or try to
even
convince them which is usually not the
case um
that's not gonna work okay so like i
come up people come up to me all the
time telling me about you know terrorism
and stuff like this or even aisha's age
and you know i'm just reading this stuff
and i'm thinking like this is gonna be
so easy
you have no idea what you're saying to
me right now
um so that's one thing know your place
secondly if you don't
know what you're talking about or you
don't have that much knowledge
you know humble yourself in the way that
you speak
you know what i mean go in there and say
look i i read this hadith and it sounds
really weird to me okay and it doesn't
sound right can you explain it to me
what is your explanation just do that
that's all you have to do is start a
discussion you don't have to go in there
and like
pedophile you know and then all of a
sudden you know like what do you expect
gonna happen after that
seriously what do you expect going to
happen
like yeah absolutely yeah
okay that's an interesting point so have
a beer so be more inquisitive rather
than assertive
that's a better way of putting it you
know don't go in there with a combative
attitude unless you're looking for
combat
because yeah i i think you know what
that that could be extended
to pretty much any discourse exactly
about anything serious you know
like you may have your hand-ups about
islam or any religion or politics
whatever you want to call it
uh and if you are a genuine truth-seeker
then maybe the approach should be
but tell me what your argument is um
you know formulate this in your own
words and let me see how i respond
rather than
me telling you what you think and then
be like ah look how could you believe
that man that's so ridiculous
uh you believe x y and z how could you
do that and then you haven't even asked
the person what they believe
you haven't even heard them out and
you've already made up your mind what
they believe and how they're going to
react to you
yeah and you know and i think a lot of
the things it has to do with also is
that you know we social media provides a
sort of
cover where we don't have to be civil to
each other
and um and and i think that's also very
problematic you know
normally people don't behave this way in
conversation
unless they're looking for like
confrontation you know i mean like
people i i i think that 90 of the people
like a lot of these ex-muslims or even
us
you know people who don't like islam
come on and say these things like
pedophile and blah blah i don't think in
real life they would behave that way
i think that yeah sorry i think that
generally like if they went up to a
muslim they would they would be more of
the inquisitive type
you know in a personal conversation
because they're they're engaging with an
actual person
and they can see people's reactions and
things and they don't there's a sense in
every human being but they don't really
want to hurt people you know what i mean
so yeah i i agree i actually agree with
that because i think when you
um when you see someone in front of you
a real human being and you see their
body language you see them physically
and you see that that they are a human
and not some something behind a screen
then you radically change the way you
have a conversation with them about
anything forget about religion
even simple things you know uh you could
change your attitude
and uh i think social media and the
internet in general i mean this is
again not even specific to islam or
religion has radically changed the way
we communicate
and it's just about you know if i type
in with caps lock that you know that
must mean i'm
so much more intense or that you know
i'm really serious about my views or if
i
uh attach a meme to what i say then you
know well
sorry mate you just got owned um and of
course it's funny or it's silly and
whatever but obviously if you want to
have a serious discussion of course then
we're having good
then if you want to have fun and poke
fun and be like no no no
great but if you don't have a serious
discussion and if you're genuine when
you want to know
the truth whatever that is then that is
a different ball game and i think that
like you were saying before
uh it's a different set of rules for
that um so yeah i mean i i would say
that that advice
goes for everyone uh muslim not muslim
religion politics
buddy the weather whatever you want to
call it i agree um
there's also a double standard here too
because i think that people generally
adopt um for example this whole the
whole thing that i mentioned about
knowledge so
when you see for example a lot of
atheists i'm sorry to pick on them a lot
but
they uh i feel very persecuted right now
sorry
but you know like when you see a lot of
like or should i say militant atheist
yes
you know they go after like say young
earth creationist right they will go
through
every academic peer-reviewed article
they can find to destroy these people
okay but when it comes to their views on
religion all of a sudden oh academia
you know these people are in their ivory
towers they don't know what they're
talking about
you know like you know they don't do any
real research
things like this you know and it's like
you you can't have your cake and eat it
too
you know you have to have standards and
yeah certainly there are
there are disagreements in academia not
every everyone is not perfect
right there are going to be problems but
there's still an
institutionalized standard within
society
that makes knowledge uh you know
possible
you know the university has its flaws
but we still need it
like you know we have to use that
discourse as a means as
a startup as a sorry as a jumping off
point
simply you know repeating you know these
these obscure opinions that you find
online from some random website or
youtube video
is not in any way shape or form
respecting
knowledge or respecting any sort of
intellectual dialogue
you know what yeah i agree and you know
what that's this may be
um what do you want to call it how do i
put this
as a you know you are an academic so um
i suppose any academic when they hear
the common man
talking about the subject like like for
example i don't know if i was a
i don't know you know if my field was
about you know
the environment or if i was a geologist
or something like that and i hear
someone say
you know global warming is x or you know
it's like it's like no no you
stop stop stop yeah you don't know the
thing is stick to that you need to
understand it's like okay i am an
academic in certain fields
but i'm also a common man in another
field but academia has taught me
to shut my mouth when somebody else is
speaking that is
that is in a different field like you
know that's the thing is like i have
learned that because
not just because of what other people
are doing outside and they're sort of
butchering
the research that i do but i've also
learned that because that's what
academia teaches you is like you need to
shut up when the other guy is talking
like you know like yeah like you know
like i'm not going to go and start
preaching
about okay for example for example i
have certain opinions about certain
political views
okay but i'm not going to go walk in to
a political science course and start
telling the professor how to do his job
okay that that is beyond the pale of
arrogance
like that it's just like that's
something don't do
you know and um but for some reason
people on the internet think it's okay
okay so of course people the internet i
mean it's it's like a
you know people in a cafe or people in
the market just
talk about whatever people on the
internet but yeah
so okay so that's an interesting point
you made this and now now i think we're
agreeing to march
people may we're not even you know that
we're actually probably in the same room
um so let me let me uh
press you on that you said that you know
if you would go into a political science
uh
with you know science lecture and say
and tell the professor
you know you've you you've read it all
wrong you have no idea what you're
talking about it's like this or
whatever you would not do that i would
not do that because you know we we know
that we are
uh outclassed in knowledge and expertise
and blah blah blah
so using that logic when
one of the things that annoyed me when i
was uh on this journey when i was sort
of
on the verge from islam to atheism or
star trek nationalism
was when i saw muslim scholars or imams
or whoever call it
talking about science like evolution
didn't happen this way
or the earth is like this and they're
not they haven't got any science
background they're not doctors they're
not medical doctors you know
like this guy um they're not any sorry
i'd had to slip that in there
um i appreciate that i appreciate that
they're not anyone with any speciality
in science yet they
and they started with muslims this was
christian to do it everyone does this
okay it's not i'm not trying to have a
guy it's not
but everyone they sort of like if
like i'm not going to tell the imam how
to pray namas or salah
fine or the theology of his religion or
the
intricacies of fick whatever but at the
same time i don't expect that mom if he
hasn't got a science background to tell
me that evolution is not real
because now you're encroaching upon the
domain of science if that makes sense
how would you
feel about that i'm fine with that
well i'm glad you are okay guys that's
all we have time for i'm joking
if you want me to tell you why sure i
mean the whole
thing about science and the quran is a
very recent invention in
islamic tradition it just occurred
within the last two centuries
actually as a result as a response to
sort of
colonial powers taking over the and also
the western world in general sort of
growing in strength and power and
and muslims being pushed into the sort
of this corner where now they have they
feel the sense of insecurity so now they
have to sort of justify their religion
through
scientific and technological means um
prior to that however
uh the majority of actually all of the
classical scholars completely
didn't even read science in the quran
like al ghazali went the farthest in
saying that
the quran mentioned science in a very
general way
like the principles of science but like
most
islamic scholars didn't even read any
sort of scientific
knowledge in the quran itself this is
not even this is not apologetics like
you can read imam shah to be
for example a famous maliki jurist who
was refuting this one
minority group within andaluse at the
time uh
who was saying oh yeah you know all of
our recent scientific theories that
we've been coming up with again
astrology like astronomy and stuff like
this they're in the quran
he was like uh the sahaba and the
prophet himself peace be upon him never
never read the quran that way so why are
you doing it
like that was basically his refutation
he was like you're done you know
why why are we and only until like
muslim modernist came along after the
fall of the
or even prior to that a little bit
during like the turkish reforms
when french positivism was becoming very
popular and things like this and even
after that
they started saying oh no no uh the
quran says something about the big bang
the quran says something about
embryology and the quran says this and
the quran says that
and it's just like
that just came out of nowhere honestly
yeah so
let's talk about that i think what
you're saying is very interesting um
talking about embryology
was it my father or some other uh i
think it's my friend who was a muslim
this is you know
some time ago and we're talking about
embryology and
i said to them do you really think the
companions or the prophet
or even people 100 or 200 years after
knew anything about embryology or even
read that verse
in the way we may read it today and
understand that it's attempting or
rightly wrongly i don't want to get into
about that
do you think they understood it like the
way you understand it um
and of course as far as i'm aware it's a
no
or if it is this is what i'm trying to
say
when people start fishing for
scientific proofs or evidences in the
quran i mean i was speaking
to dr osama hassan uh who i've got a lot
of respect for he's a i think he's a
fantastic guy and
a fantastic learned man a muslim and
he's an astrophysicist
and he was saying that muslims there was
this time where you know that story of
joseph
uh islam where he took about his dream
and his dream saw
12 moons of control planets and um sorry
12 stars where it was
some of that and someone said oh that
you know that's proof for the 12 planets
in our solar system and that's proven by
the quran
so we were there before you guys and
then some years later it was discovered
that that wasn't a planet
it was like a moon or something in our
solar system and he said
you've now just falsified the quran so
once you start
attaching scientific miracles you know
from the quran into the real world
and if they were later to be proven
wrong you've just falsified the quran
and
you know yeah that's problematic also
since science is continuously changing
um but like for example let me give you
give me some give you some examples of
classical interpretations because you
know some individuals also in your
chatter
are making the statement that the you
know sort of mocking the the idea that
is not speaking about scientific facts
so for example
in several passages in the quran allah
says that he laid the earth out flat
okay um all classical mufasir
um including ibn abbas who was one of
the first uh major
uh okay basically said that this
verse is talking about uh arab
hospitality
and what they mean by that is that when
the arabs went out to the desert
okay what they would do is because there
was rocky or hilly terrain
they would flatten out the earth below
their feet before they put the rug down
okay to make it comfortable for people
to live
i mean you can just look this up right
now you don't even have you can go to
the qtuffshear.com
look up even cathear and he'll mention
it you know even if a boss's opinion
below that
okay none of them said oh you know the
world was flat you know that's not how
they interpreted that that passage
uh likewise with other scientific
phenomena in the quran you know
everything the quran says was basically
common knowledge to the arabs at the
time and it was being
expressed in a way that tried to give
them the impression of god's mercy
and god's purpose for their existence
that was it
that's the only reason that they were
even mentioned like even the whole thing
about the fresh water and the salt water
it's like oh look at that see god is is
doing this for you and things like it
was all teleological
it had nothing to do with oh hey guys uh
quantum physics
you know like what would be the purpose
of that
and you know yeah here's another
argument too how would the muslims
because by the way the golden age did
happen all right a lot of people try to
deny it but it did
um about you know within two centuries
after the muslims
you know conquered the surrounding
regions you know scientific advancement
went you know production went crazy okay
skyrocketed
and the reason for this is because the
muslims back then didn't read science in
the quran
because if they had read science in the
quran then how would they have been able
to have such
you know uh such an open mind about so
many scientific theories
if they could just read in the quran be
like oh it's there we don't need to
research anymore
they didn't do that
that's a very interesting point you made
there um you know you mentioned that i
think about the
uh the bfs we have spread the earth flat
like a carpet i think that's that i
think that's the
verse in the chrono you can correct me
if i'm wrong um i was
i think it was dr osama hussein again he
said that i think i don't want to
misquote if
imam sayuti he actually he said the
earth
he's he used that verse to say the earth
is flat but there was another muslim
scientist
who said no well imam
mentioned just the literal translation
of words you have to understand about
is essentially a linguistic commentary
it has no mention it has very few
mentions of hadith or fick
or how things should be the case i mean
it's primarily about grammar
that's why it's considered uh a
beginner's tough seer
a lot of people like to use it but let's
say let's take that as an argument let's
say that uh imam sayuti did mention that
the earth is actually flat and that we
don't live on this round
sphere okay um
many tough seers prior to him said the
opposite
many more conservative scholars like for
instance ibn thamia even
they all mentioned that the earth was
round and they interpreted the quran in
the same fashion and
they interpret the quran in the same
fashion that i mentioned earlier they
never mentioned that oh this thing
so i mean if you want to use a later
tough theater okay because this is a
medieval tufts here that we're talking
about
over the classical scholars then i think
that's going to be a little bit of a
problem
uh because it's sort of like saying well
um well how do i put this generally when
we're doing like
um historical surveys or we're trying to
examine
what the actual interpretation is in
accordance with like the first
generation of muslims we're going to go
to the earliest source material we're
not going to go to the later source
material
that's like me saying oh let's use the
19th and 20th century tufts here that
mention scientific miracles to interpret
what the muslims back then believe
like that that's not fair i mean in that
case there's just two
two points uh would you categorically
say
because what you're saying is very
interesting actually i must say would
you categorically say imams
or sheikh scholars whoever they may be
who are not
who do not have a science background or
even if they do have a science
background
should not be in the business of trying
to derive
any scientific miracles claims from the
quran or
the hadees yes i think it's wrong for
anyone with the i think it's wrong in
general even if you have a science
background to interpret science in the
quran i think this is wrong
okay fair enough i think i think that's
a very fair statement
and the second thing is if what you're
saying you know that the
class that the classical uh
tough series are more accurate and
closer to the actual
prophet and the sahabas and whatnot the
companions is there any point in writing
youth of series after like 200 years
because it's just getting more and more
further away from the actual source
what's the point of so for example if
someone today said i want to write out
of syria you'd be like what was the
point we've already got some
it depends on what the the intention of
the tough series so for example if
you're trying to
um write about like contemporary events
like if you're doing it from like a
thicky perspective right
because fic is constantly evolving right
then that would be okay because like
you're trying to bring in like how what
does this
earlier ruling you know uh apply to
today
things like that like that's okay um
you know if you're trying to do like a
linguistic commentary that hasn't been
translated yet or something that makes
sense you know but like in basically
trying to include things in there that
the classical scholars themselves
did not originally intend that makes no
sense
that that to me that's that's completely
wrong and i'm not the only one saying
this it's not apologetics i mean like i
said classical scholars both uh
all opposed this sort of interpretive
method and even many contemporary
scholars today are saying this is wrong
i mean this is not how you should be
doing it now it's caught on
for a large amount of people for i think
many reasons that i expressed earlier
especially with the whole
internet culture but uh it's not it's
not
it's not considered a sound way of
looking at it
so let me ask you do i mean uh you
said you know that you would not favor
uh any scholar or imam whoever may be
um trying to derive some sort of i don't
know scientific miracles or claims from
the quran
would you i mean so what is your uh sort
of position on like things like
evolution adam and eve
uh do you look at this as a conflict or
do you just
leave it there's a problem with it to be
honest i have no problem with evolution
um generally speaking although i mean to
be honest with you i
i think that um the whole conception
of like uh like i also have no i have a
problem with common ancestry but what i
have a problem with
is you know here's where i guess you
could say there's a conflict right
that's right yeah sorry god
so i think it's a conflict but you know
so allah says that he made adam and eve
okay now we don't know the exact
process of how that occurred or anything
like that but i do believe that there
were actually two special individuals
who created
now i don't know how that necessarily
fits in or contradicts the evolutionary
theory
i don't think it does because from my
understanding of evolutionary theory
it's not
that absolutist when it comes to you
know it doesn't say
it's something sit there and deny that
adam and eve couldn't possibly existed
or not
um so i i don't really see how there's a
conflict there
um i mean that's about as far as it
would go in terms of conflict if you
were to even think about it that way
for me personally but like i follow
evolutionary theory i have no problem
with it um
you know i think it's it's also very
helpful in terms of understanding um
human development over time uh like even
for example even with the aisha issue
and that was brought up earlier you know
for me i use evolutionary theory with
respect to that
and explaining sort of our biological
social conditions and how that would
have been morally acceptable back then
um etc etc so
personally i don't really see an issue
with it and it's not even a matter of
cognitive dissonance i just don't
doesn't bother me at all
okay so fair enough so let me uh play
the role of
a muslim who would have have a problem
with
it and say to you yeah ali
[Laughter]
yeah ali how could you say something
like that brother if
you know adam and eve is mentioned in
the quran that allah created adam and
eve
he created adam from clay and he created
uh eve out of
uh of his rib although that's not in the
quran i think that's in
nevertheless um allah mentioned that he
fashioned them with his hands
he actually created them and you're
telling me
that you know a biological or a natural
process of evolution which is basically
from
some one-celled organism to a fish to a
monkey
to a human being that's how we so you're
saying that
adam's father or great ancestor is a
monkey how could you possibly say that
well for example
what does that even mean like uh you
know even in the evolutionary
the current standard evolutionary story
is that uh you know we're cousins to
apes
yeah of course i i know it's not like
exact exactly
so so if they were to say listen man
well i would say that allah
made a special creation it's not it
doesn't it doesn't have to destroy
evolutionary
revolution it doesn't oppose it i mean
if you believe in god it's not like it's
difficult to believe that would happen
yeah it's like relax so
i mean look so the partner says that
when they say when they look at the
quran and they look at the stories
within the quran the verses and they say
god did
x he created adam then this happened and
and you're saying
there's no problem with evolution i
i don't know if you're aware some years
ago there was this conference in the
in london have muslims misunderstood
evolution i'm not sure if you're aware
of that
um uh anyway i was there and uh
jason was there osama hussein was there
it was actually hosted by adam dean
and adam yeah so
uh what do you want to call it um dr
osama hussain said that he had so many
muslims
come up to him and say i think i'm
losing my faith because when i'm in
science class or when i'm doing my work
in the lab i know evolution is true but
when i go to the mosque
they're telling me it's not they're
telling me creationism and adam and eve
and god and this whole story
and a lot of people muslims were in that
and actually i was as well to be
completely honest with you in that i
don't know who to believe anymore i
don't know who to look at
so um i i would encourage you
uh and people like yourself to speak to
these imams or shakes whatever it is
who are pushing the no evolution is not
real uh it's creationism
um push against that narrative you know
oh yeah no we do
to be honest like i bring it up all the
time uh i was critiquing
no offense to brother hamza but i was
critiquing brother holmes of sorts his
arguments way before he even recanted
them
i was sending him even personal messages
telling him look this is wrong
like you know i'm not trying to put
myself above him but i'm just telling
you like you know
like i was i was we were you know people
were going out of their way there was a
reason he recanted
and you you you paid a hand in that well
i think so i hope so wow
i've got to respect that because uh you
know um
he was someone who was pushing the whole
science miracles
quite a lot in the early days um
and you know when he said you know when
he took back his position he said no we
can't do that we can't
take scientific miracles from the quran
everyone was like well you've just been
pushing this for the last five ten years
and you're telling me
nevertheless people can change their
mind uh so i i
at least respect him for his uh changing
position uh and if you had a hand to
play in that then uh you know you have
uh
you are the puppeteer you are the man
behind the scenes
i'm just one of the people that might
have talked to them but you know the
thing is
is that one of the ways that we address
this as i mentioned first off is you
have to bring
muslims back to the sort of traditional
classical perspective on a lot of things
um like i said the whole issue with
science in the quran is a recent
invention a lot of muslims don't know
this and once you show them the
evidences
from the past from other scholars like
imam schatterby and others
who oppose this this even even thinking
about it
you know i mean like they will start to
change their minds you know
and there you know a lot of a lot of
uh should i say ex-muslims
uh and even just people who are against
islam in general have been using this as
some sort of like
you know beating stick against islam
like oh i see islam is so ridiculous
because it mentions this and this and
the scientist
it's like you do realize that that's
just a recent perspective like you're
only attacking
what is could only be considered sort of
a heretical viewpoint
of the quran itself no offense i mean
you know but
you're only you're only helping muslims
to go back to a more traditional
understanding of their faith
um so when you see some of these i see
some like um
i don't forget who they are anyway some
online polemicist always like attacking
the scientific miracles i'm like
okay how about it i don't care
like you know like who cares what you
mean like it's not like you're going to
be changing anything radically about how
islam is understood
when you when you get people to reject
that if you're thinking that you're
going to get people to reject islam in
general
then all it means is that the people who
are rejecting islam don't know their
tradition
that's really it no offense i mean if
that's your intention
you know um well i mean that's that's a
very interesting point because um
you're saying i mean i'm going to take
your position to be true
because you know for the sake of the
argument
if the real islam is classical islam
whatever that means or however you want
to interpret or however you want to
define that
people that are born in a period where
classical islam is not
maybe the main mainstream narrative or
the main
thing taught in mosques and schools or
whatever it is and if they reject a
non-classical version of islam
on some level i mean it's not their
fault entirely because not everyone has
the resources
all the time to do as much research or
have the ability to do that so they're
like
yeah i'm not really sure man evolution
is this and you're telling me it's not
so you know what
if i've got to make up my mind i'd
rather go with you know science
rather than religion or whatever it is
so i mean how many
and this is what i i have a
not a problem with islam but a problem
in general with regards to religion
is which version of islam or which
which version of christianity or
whatever you want to call it but for the
sake of argument islam
which version of islam are we talking
about here because i can guarantee you
um this with you know the same authority
or sort of not an authority in a sort of
arrogant way but in a sort of a yakin
way with the same certainty with which
you speak
you've done your research and you come
to these conclusions you will have
people with that same certainty about a
sufi version or a shia version or a
this that you know x y and z version
salafi isis whatever you're going to
call it and you can say oh they're
they're wrong or whatever it is and i
might even agree with you they may be
wrong if you were to look at the sources
but that's the point so
if i am rejecting one version of islam
because that was the version that was
given to me or that was the most
dominant version around me or
i mean this is it you know can the real
muslims please stand up you know it's
that song you know emma by eminem
well i think the question has a lot of
implications in there i mean
for one i guess you're asking can you
blame these people for leaving something
that they don't
oh that that's the only you know
modality that they understand
right like and i don't think you can and
i think that i think that's that's one
of the other issues with
that's one of the issues with
contemporary apostasy laws is that
there are a lot of muslims out there who
have been fed a sort of modernist
understanding
of the religion and for all intents and
purposes haven't even been raised
religious
i mean for example you know you look at
a lot of muslim majority countries today
like bangladesh and like you think oh
yeah
these people are like practicing mullahs
and it's like no half of them are more
western than westerners
it's like you know and then when they
leave they have no idea what they left
you know they're leaving because they
don't like some of the practices the
cultural elements that are involved in
there they haven't even done any
research they don't like it they just
don't like what they're dealing with and
they leave it
you know can you really blame them is it
fair
um and i don't think it is
i don't think it's fair to blame them
for something like that
uh for something they don't have very
little understanding they have some very
little understanding of you know
um and i think that uh that's one reason
why
contemporary apostasy laws are
problematic
uh in a practical sense um
so
sorry one more implication you made with
regards to certainty i
i don't think certainty from either side
makes people makes their arguments valid
you know like yeah i'm certain somebody
else is certain you're certain i'm
certain but who cares
you know like what regardless of ours i
mean obviously we're certain that's why
we're disagreeing with each other
but that doesn't that doesn't make one's
position valid over another
you know what we have to do is we have
to take an honest appraisal of our own
views
examine what is the most coherent and
rational position to take
for that particular belief that we claim
to be following
you know that's really how it should be
done and you know i'm not saying it's
it's easy
but um it's certainly not that the
differences of opinion are certainly not
an
indication that there isn't a right way
to understand something
yeah yeah i mean that's that's that's a
fair point um so
let's talk about i mean we're speaking
about science and uh sort of evidence
proof academia
so how this is one of the things that
i really struggle with how do i know the
quran
is from god i mean first of all number
one premise there is a god second
second second premise uh which for me is
a harder premise
the the god part for me is still hard
but the harder one is
god spoke to man and this is what he
said
of course over a period of 20 years and
blah blah nevertheless
god spoke to man and these were god's
words
how does one establish that beyond any
doubt or
with the you know with the least
possible doubt you know
physically possible
with regard to what exactly like that
there's like that that the quran
is the word of god and firstly there is
a god but we
let's look at that but let's assume
there is a god but for me
just because there is a god there's no
there's no evidence or rationality that
he even wants to speak to us and if he
did speak to us that he spoke to us in
this way
that's that's for me is a very big claim
how do you understand that that's not
true well how do you first of all
how do you recognize well why do you
recognize there's a god and why do you
assume that he doesn't want to
interact with humans i can't assume
either way
okay so and why would you assume that
it's irrational that he would
i'm i'm agnostic i i i don't know if i
don't know if you would i don't know if
you wouldn't
i think if if the assertion that's why i
would i would classify myself as
agnostic
i cannot say there is a rational reason
for god to speak to humans or there
isn't a rational reason
i don't know genuinely you're agnostic
about your you're agnostic about
theism but not deism uh i'm agnostic
about what you mean you're okay with god
existing but you're you're agnostic in
respects to if he interacts with the
world or not
i'm agnostic about whether i'm agnostic
now because i'm kind of achieved
okay i think i've tied myself up in a
circle so i'm saying for the sake of i'm
saying for the sake of argument let's
assume there is a god
you know that that that that's a given
okay
even then if i were to assume that
there is no for me like how do you get
from
someone who created a universe to he is
now speaking to
this tiny species on this planet
that's in this vast universe that's a
big jump for me
and how do you know that the quran is
the word that's that's what i'm trying
to say
well it's like it's kind of it kind of
asks another question prior to that is
why would he create such a tiny
thing in this vast universe if he's not
going to talk to him
does he talk to plants or animals or i
don't know
i mean this is what i'm saying too the
why
is a very good question but but i don't
have an answer for that but i'm
i think human beings again this is
uh sort of the ego of the human that we
are the center of the universe and god
created us and he's speaking to me and
speaking to us and this is his message
to me and us because he wants us to live
in this way because he's going to take
us to heaven
many many assumptions and many and a lot
of them are
because we are because human beings are
so special on some level we are special
but
not that special when you look at the
magnitude of the universe
um so for me that's a big jump
personally speaking and i
i when i thought about it i thought i
don't have a rational or empirical
it's not proof in the evidence on the in
the rocks or the in the atom
to say that god did this yeah well first
of all
i didn't mean to uh i have to listen to
what you're saying you know
um you know one of the things that i
that i've always found fascinating about
i hear this a lot you know humans have
this big ego and we want to be special
and blah blah blah
i was like i never thought that humans
collectively thought that way about
themselves
um you know i've always thought that
humans
had a tendency to believe these things
more because
first off it was sort of natural to do
so and secondly because you know we're
communicative creatures
and we are creatures that need to
communicate and need to understand the
world through personal intention and
purpose
and that was just sort of like that's
why it's just rational to believe that
that there is that's partly why it's
rational to believe why
why god would want to communicate back
you know i mean like
it wasn't because oh we're these special
things in the middle of everywhere
in the middle of nowhere and you know
it's like i never thought it had to do
with ego so much as it had to do
just with the way people are
you know as humans it's like you know if
you're on if you're deserted on a desert
island
you know one of the things that you
crave more than anything that that
really solidifies your sanity
is human interaction you know
you know you saw the movie castaway i
presume
yeah it's like you know
eventually he had to talk to him it's
not a true story but he had to talk to a
volleyball
but the reason they showed that was to
represent
that that need that essential human need
for the condition of mankind
to have communication um even with the
universe
so i don't think it has anything to do
with ego i think it has to do with
necessity
life that's a very interesting point
actually i i think that's a very fair
point
actually i i think uh that's a yeah so
it's this need like if you're
you know in the middle of a desert or
you're
stranded in an island or you're
[Music]
you know plunged into a deep river and
you're about to sink and die and you're
sort of like
come on something out there the mind
just does not
it it force human beings do not choose
do not
voluntarily look at the world and seek
something that isn't there do you know
what i'm trying to say like they don't
people have this idea about god where
like people just like try to imagine
that like they force themselves to
imagine that there's like this
creature out there or something that's
going to come save them you know
as like they're forcing themselves to
have a coping mechanism
well i don't think that's how it works i
think the human mind just automatically
creates that
you know what i mean like it just it
it's there you know
that's just the mind's natural tendency
um
so i mean that's a very interesting
point though so you said that we have
this need
or this sort of uh this this thirst for
communication because we are
the oh i think we are the most evolved
species that on this earth anyway that
you know in terms of communication
that's what separates us from any other
animal i suppose
is our is the way that we can
communicate so do you think that
this is just an extension of that and
we've
projected that onto god of god we've
created a god or prophet
so whatever you want to call it well
let's let's let's assume that yes there
because i i
tend to i take a very um
different approach when i think a lot of
modernist muslims in terms of how to
rationalize belief
in god so um for me that natural
tendency
pointing towards that existence even if
you want to call it projection is in and
of itself sort of a rational default
um because it's something that's
involuntary it's something that we can't
really help control
and it's something that that it gives us
a starting point
now i've i've offered other arguments
you know after that you know
because when you come from a rational
starting point it doesn't necessitate
that the thing itself actually exists
right but it gives us sort of a reason
to do so
and um
so my argument in response to sort of it
being a projection is that
well you're talking about something that
is way beyond
the limitations of the natural world uh
something that
we can't just examine and then infer
that it's there
right you've said it yourself like you
don't look at a rock and then all of a
sudden like god
you know it doesn't just pop into your
mind right
so my argument in response to that would
be well
if there is nothing in the world that is
pointing towards god
as any sort of explicit indication then
how are we really how are we
conceptualizing that that the
possibility of such an entity
in such a limited reference
that's a that's an interesting question
um and i
genuinely don't sound uh mean to sound
facetious or anything like that
but i mean for centuries and millennia
we
believed in i don't know witches or
the boogeyman or some sort of other
creatures like mim
yeah creatures and so on and so forth
and
of course uh one could say that those
were the
you know we filled those spaces of
mystery with what we could do best
you know we feel those mystery spaces
that we couldn't explain with science or
reason rationality and we said
well this kind of creature must be doing
it or this kind of person
must be doing this sort of function you
know but when it rains it must be
because
someone is angry in the sky or whatever
it is but what's fascinating about your
objection there and i always found very
fascinating about this general objection
about
santa claus and spaghetti monsters and
fairies and unicorns
is that they're all composites of the
natural world
um a flying spaghetti monster is
something that flies in spaghetti
it's something that you can empirically
verify unicorns are horns with horses on
their head
i'm sorry excuse me let me reverse that
unicorns are horses with horns on their
head
something that you can empirically
verify and combine you know
uh you're talking about santa claus for
you know people bring up santa claus
fat guy in a red suit delivering
presents how is that not empirically uh
verifiable you know these are things
that people can invent
imagine because they've already
experienced them and then just combine
them into these little things
and they use them as a reference point
right god is
is that's a completely more complex and
different matter that
you can't just you know i can't look at
my phone and then take this book and put
it together and be like oh there's god
you know like it doesn't work that way
um you know so i feel that that that
objection i know you weren't being
facetious but i do feel that that
objection
misses the entire point um
and i feel that it's not it's not an
accurate representation of how theists
come to believe things either
um and i think that's one of the reasons
one of the reasons we have a problem
communicating with each other atheists
and theists in general is because
atheists didn't have this very crude
representation of what's going on
in the psyche of theist and then also
that that existential experience
and i think uh theists have a hard time
defining what that is you know
um now i i to be honest with you i don't
want to get into this huge philosophical
discussion and because i want to get to
other things but i want to say that i
feel that that is not a
accurate representation of how theists
believe or why they believe
that's a fair point of course i i
appreciate you know everything you're
saying and the
openness with which you're saying it um
because one of the things that i
you know when i was muslim i i was like
even if i
don't get islam like i i might not be
able to understand the correct version
of islam or whatever it is
but for me i had a very hard time saying
how can they not be a god
how on earth has this all come into
existence if you were to go back in time
rewind the tape of the of the universe
you know there has to be some point
where someone
something pushed the first domino and
i would say that was god now before we
get to define god oh god is loving but
forget all that loving merciful
forget all that nonsense because that is
not for the time being
but just as a creator
in the like i couldn't i couldn't
perceive their
a universe without a god so i i think so
i mean it's the same way you know if i
woke like i don't know this is about a
bad argument
i'm trying to help i want to help you
kind of also
you know communicate that thought
yeah because look there's nothing wrong
with that view because it's a natural
tendency
and once it's the same it's the same
natural tendency that you have to view
that there's morality
or that there's purpose in life you know
those things are not scientifically
verifiable
and yet we believe them rationally it's
the same tendency that you have to see
intrinsic value in other human beings
there's a rash that's that's what makes
it rational is that it's part of your
human condition
you know people might say well natural
things don't don't prove the validity of
certain things
and that's true they don't prove they
don't prove the existence
the actual thing is is there okay
but it gives us a rational story because
what are you gonna do you're a human
being it's not like you can be anything
else
it's not like you can control the
tendencies you know what i mean
and that's what that's kind of where i'm
coming from here and
and i'm trying to break this down to
simple terms as possible
is that this natural inclinations are
how humans operate in the world
most of the physical most excuse me most
of the social structures that we have
human rights political structures these
are all
subjectively derived experiences that we
place some sort of reality in because we
have no other choice but to do so
um everything that you think is moral
has no scientific verification
there is absolutely zero tangibility
to to what you think is wrong or right
about
somebody's actions i i would disagree
with that because
let's say for example i don't know um
i i
someone beats their child
uh and you know there have been many
tests many
research whatever you want to call it
reports saying that if you beat your
children
when they're young it produces certain
chemicals in their brain and we can
measure this and they usually have
very negative effects when they're older
so on and so forth now
i haven't had to refer to god or any
book i'm just looking at the data
so i can say using science that it's bad
to hit your children
and i'm sure there are many other
experiments or whatever research is
about to hit people
unprovoked whatever because it's for
for various reasons because it produces
this and that and persons it has a
negative impact on the development
so so we can make these statements
without having to
lean on any claim about supernatural god
or creator or profit or anything like
that
so what i mean what would you say to
that and there are many other examples
of well
personally i think that's a little bit
of a strong man because i mentioned that
there's a natural tendency to feel some
sort of revolution or
or some sort of uh desire to
or oh yeah i i mean the the the last
part where you said that uh
maybe i misunderstood it about the last
part saying
no no yeah what i'm trying to say is
that these are sort of subjectively
derived from human condition
okay so for example i know when i see
somebody getting
unjustly treated right that there's a
natural inclination in my mind
that that's something wrong okay there's
something wrong with that
right and it's not science telling me
that like you can read all these reports
and say oh yeah
it's bad for the development but what do
you mean bad for their development
that's sort of assumed
like what bad is you know what i mean so
for let me give you an example of
somebody who's who's not
normative in society somebody who has a
problem that we can consider that i
think we can all agree on as a human
civilization has an issue
okay a psychopath example
you know somebody who has zero empathy
for his victims who thinks it's a game
to hunt and kill people
like you know that those inclinations
don't arrive in their mind even if you
told them you gave them a scientific oh
look see it says
it's bad for their development do you
think they're going to care
like [__] oh yeah they may not care
but what i'm trying to say
what can i say is when you say natural
uh thinking so
even if i even if me and you think
something is natural
it's just my mind and your perception it
could be
not just because we think it's natural
that doesn't mean it's true so what when
i say look at the data
we're verifying whether or not it's true
or not you're verifying what you've
already feel compelled to believe in
no i mean for the vast majority of human
history and even now
people think it's okay to beat their
children
yeah and but the evidence would say
otherwise it's bad for their development
in terms of
maybe shorter lifespans they're more
violent when they grow up they have less
empathy all these different things which
i don't want to make about being true so
the reasons they believe that the reason
they believe
that it's okay to hit their children for
example because it's not true
because it's the thing because it's
hierarchy for example well no they're
thinking that for example this is going
to this is sort of disciplinary action
and this is going to help them in their
development they're not doing it because
they think oh
it's bad for them i like doing this
because it hurts my child
they they i mean i was beating i was hit
by my
parents i'm their pet they're sorry so
forth and they were saying
i'm doing it because it's good for you
so in their mind this is a natural thing
if someone steps out of line
the correct response is you hit them now
the evidence says something else
yeah i mean the thing is what i'm trying
to say is that there is
sorry is that science can inform us of
the details and what we in sort of the
direction we should go
but how we and how we infer what is
unjust
and what is wrong is sort of an
automatic thing it's not something that
we ration
it's not like we actually like think
about it for like
is murder wrong and then we sit there
you know
we're not we're undecided about the
issue you know what i mean until we've
we've had this long complicated
discussion in our mind
that there's something really wrong
about it you know we tend to
make those arguments post hoc you know
what i mean like oh here's the reason
why it's wrong
because i already feel this way you know
that's what i'm trying to say
you know what i mean the details that's
fair enough yeah that's fair enough
the details wouldn't have to be tend to
be where the confusions come in
like the context of of of the injustice
that's being performed or
or this justice is being performed you
know
the less data you have for example the
less informed you're going to be about
whether this thing really
is just or not just right yeah
but let let's say for example we were so
like you said that we
uh as a post talker that we then justify
murder is wrong
we give the reasons why it's wrong as
opposed to working out in the first
place white frog
but let's say we were able to say why
murder is wrong would that
law to say murder is not wrong become
even more powerful even more
uh sort of that's you know that's why we
rationalize things to begin with because
we want an explanation
yeah i mean that's the reason why i mean
yeah of course it
puts more force to it but it doesn't
but if we don't for example have this
complex argument as to why murder is
wrong it doesn't all of a sudden mean
that our natural inclination to believe
that
injustice is is bad suddenly becomes
irrational or suddenly becomes
undermined as a result of that
you see what i'm trying to say like that
the human society would not function
if we if we had to continuously try to
justify a lot of these inclinations
yeah like that's what i'm trying to see
i'm giving a more pragmatic
understanding like i'm a pragmatist by
philosophical
quote-unquote profession or field
whatever you want to call me but you
know so this is something that you know
uh that um even the islamic tradition
kind of
holds on to is this belief in the fitra
which is sort of this natural
inclination to believe in god and
morality and goodness and things like
this of course the details is where
things usually get muddled where we have
to have more details to understand
things
but generally this belief like belief in
god isn't
it is considered in almost in the same
category as goodness itself or
or belief that something is wrong or you
know things like this
so that's where the natural stand
standard comes in
as sort of a jumping off point and what
i feel that atheists do
quite wrongly in many ways is that
they are always asking for verification
of that natural inclination but not of
the other ones that they have
um i'm sorry uh so for example human
rights
like there is no such thing as human
rights from a subjective purely
naturalistic standpoint
they're just they just don't exist
they're not there
they don't have there's no real real
value
you know like some transcendental value
that we have to respect about
each other you know it just doesn't
exist
um so i mean we have to we operate in
that way
because if we don't we're just going to
completely wipe each other out
i think what you just said i think what
you just said there actually
for me is the strongest uh
not not evidence but the strongest
reason to have human rights because we
would
i think on some level wipe each other
out so for example if we were to
um look at the best or the most
functionable or i'm sorry the most
productive societies where the
human beings flourished they would
usually consist of some sort of rights
on some level individual rights people
can say what they want as long as
they're not into violence
you shouldn't be able to just go into
someone's house steal their property
sleep with their wife kill
so if you were to sort of look at
history and take the best of all the
societies you probably come up i'm
guessing
on some level come up with something
pretty close to human rights so in the
very long experiment of human existence
we could say that these rights probably
they may not be perfect fine nothing is
perfect i would say
but they probably are the best shot the
best
chance we have in living in a peaceful
world or a at least
the most peaceful world we could
possibly have if you were to follow
these rules
but they're based on looking back at um
our history and saying what's the best
as opposed to god said x therefore
that's where i disagree the thing is i
think that a lot of the whole
survivalists
the survivalist mentality is sort of
post-hoc rationalization
and i also feel that i think the past is
unfairly depicted
a lot of times especially obviously
contemporary period we have this
this mythological view of ourselves that
we are somehow so much more superior
morally in the past and i think that's a
huge issue
that needs to be dealt with and i'm
dealing with in my mind my next paper
for ya keen institute actually
and what i mean by this is that people
have this very anachronistic view of
history where they try to depict
the past as having the same conditions
as we do today
and then they we apply our moral
standards to them back then without
realizing what those conditions may or
may not have been
so what i mean by this for example is
that um
uh we look at like past societies and
how they operated
okay and we'll look at this one rule and
be like oh my god this is so unjust like
why would they do this
without actually realizing the reasons
behind they do it and what the
conditions were around those
those rulings like were they trying to
optimize well maybe
they were trying to optimize the best
possible solution
for what they had which was almost
nothing you know what i mean in
comparison today
like yeah um were they trying to and i'm
not trying to say that this somehow
makes everything that people did in the
past necessarily correct
but what i am trying to say is that i
think we unfairly judge past societies
as being these
immorally monstrous you know
civilizations that had
absolutely nothing to give or any sort
of wisdom whatsoever they're all just a
bunch of idiot brutes
who had no idea what it means to live a
good life and it's like
i i don't think that was the case i
think that's a
horribly horrible misrepresentation
of how people if that was really the
case how the hell did we get here
yeah i mean we were finished before we
even started um
you know so you mentioned something
about the past
and certain rules or laws about the past
which may have made sense back then
you know i'm a satirist i like making
comedy videos i believe in free speech
do you think islam
according to the classical scholars uh
the ones that you accept
promotes free speech or do you think it
is compatible with free speech with
comedy with mockery with ridicule
i mean these are things which i you know
take very seriously that's not to say i
i always really could everyone i meet or
anything like that but i do believe it
should be used
or that it can be used as a tool
to highlight illogical things i mean or
uh
silly things or even dangerous things
you know if you've got a leader that's
saying
dangerous things then you can write an
academic paper or an article or you can
do a five-minute
sketch so i i i really think you know
what is your p according to the
classical scholars is islam
compatible with free speech and
obviously that then goes on to
freedom of religion so if someone really
leads islam should there be any
punishment
so you want to move from speech to well
i mean i think
speech in the sense i should be able to
express my own views so if i want to
express my
leaving a religion or joining a religion
should i be punished
and we are both people who have changed
our minds
um i think that there's a um
there is obviously free speech within
there are principles of free speech
within islamic discourse
throughout time there have never been
really rules on speech per se
uh there have been limitations to what
one can or cannot say
in the context of the islamic
civilization or islamic society
so for example there was no i mean like
you couldn't as a muslim
mock or as a citizen of the islamic
politic mock the
the the religion or mock the um
of the prophet's character why because
my first question is why because it's
already assumed that there was there was
these are perfect standards and that was
the foundation of the society in which
they were living
so you could mock for instance the
leaders of the country like they didn't
care about that usually well you know
actually some caleb's did they they
tended to to um
what does it utilize religious doctrines
in order to make themselves out to be
infallible too in some in certain cases
and then of course they would go kill
their opposition
that's been having that's been happening
forever anyway um
so generally you know like uh
political leaders and stuff were open
for debate
and they were actually they allowed
debates between different religions you
know even
so christians and jews could debate with
muslims and things like this but
generally
insults or what was what constituted as
sort of crude
accusations were documented under
and i'm trying to use contemporary
language here because that's not how
they would call it but
would basically documented what we call
libel and slander today
so that's well language standard is not
the same as vmock so if i say
like if i were to make a joke about the
prophet or what that's not
well if you said like the prophet was
this
okay let's say for example this is a
silly it's not even funny but let's just
say for example oh the prophet was
really fat
okay like you say it's like a playground
like oh you're really fat or you
oh you smell ha ha ha if i said well
what the scholars would do is that they
would first off determine whether or not
the statement was factual
or it was made in such a way that was
meant
to invoke um some sort of like
it was basically they tried to examine
the intentions of the person
okay that's how it was so if i say i was
joking
you were joking in what sense they would
say they would ask i would say i was
trying to make a joke
uh i was trying to make a factual
statement about the prophet i didn't
mean to try to
deride like his character or hurt or you
know try to insult that's how the
classical scholars would look at is if
there was no negative intention behind
it
then there was no reason to be alarmed
by or anything like so if you said
fringes aisha was playful
or something like this you know or or
teased about
how the prophet teased her and things
like this nobody would care but
generally when it came to like if you
said something like
the whole pedophile thing earlier that
would be taken very seriously
extremely seriously because that's like
for them the classical scholars in
general that's like that's that's
slander
that's just complete libel even if you
write it down like that's just horrible
thing to say and there's no effect
behind it so you're saying so if i if i
said
there are 10 moons that's not a factual
statement
but it's not slanderous but it's a lie
it's a lie yeah so why wouldn't i be
punished for that or if i said the king
yes
between a lie and a slanderer i mean one
one is is violating somebody's
reputation
the other one is ah okay so reputation
so this is interesting because
reputation is the one thing
that you that is about you that you
don't own
you don't own your reputation as in
let's say for example
i think i'm an amazing guy i think you
know what
i think you know what i'm so funny i'm
the funniest kind of planet that but it
it doesn't matter what i think about my
what i think my my reputation should be
it's up to other people to decide what
they think of me so i don't actually own
my reputation for that sense that you
have every right to protect your honor
or to have
i can i can you know protect my owner
but you know i don't know about taking
people to court if they say
if somebody tells me i'm terrorism start
getting like a bunch of like
you know uh you know and my reputation
has been ruined and people think that
i'm actually a terrorist
you know that's not cool like you know i
have i should have a right
by the law to object not only object to
that but defend my honor
yeah and that's like that's not fair i
think that i think there is a difference
between
mocking and slander um so if i
like accuse you of being a like not yeah
if i accuse you
you know what allah i know he killed
someone like that's something different
i'm not saying you did i'm not saying
you didn't either i'm sure uh but if i
say you know
i think absolutely man he is like i
don't know
he's really fat he's i don't believe
this he's really fat he's very ugly
and his breath stinks and you know he's
like
really bad at taekwondo right i've
completely
ruined your reputation but if i said the
same thing about the prophet
like i should be punished okay that's
what okay so in the classic islamic
polity basically
the essential uh understanding was that
profit and allah were off limits and the
companions were off limits
uh by sort of basically divine decree
and that was it so so my understanding
would be and this is i remember when
charlie hebdo happened and i was muslim
i was like you know what i it became
such a
you for me personally such a useless oh
you can't say that about the prophet
you can't you can't so guys let him say
what they want
i believe in the prophet and my opinion
of the prophet
is not going to uh you know it's not
going to change if someone draws a
cartoon in france
so i'm like why can't islam stand up to
mockery and ridicule i mean it's a
massive claim
to make not just islam any religion or
any major
assertion you know about anyone's life
this is the perfect way to live
why can't you sustain criticism that is
mockery or
whatever you want to call it like oh the
prophet is a fat you smelly
i mean it's not true i can't prove it
but if i want to do it yeah i give two
arguments to that well first off
uh i think that muslims these days of
course should do so
um i think that's the only i mean we
have to that's there's no there's no
you know we have to take on every
criticism
regardless of whether or not it's
considered crude or not okay that's the
that's the position i take as well uh
that's why i respond to every criticism
regardless of its
uh its crude nature or its lack of crude
you know crudeness
i i tackle all of them you know what i
mean and i
condemn anyone who uh tries to violate
the rules of engagement i'm not trying
to harm people for example right
i mean if someone has passed away
well you know hold on so anyway so like
when charlie hebdo happened i condemned
that
and the reason i did had not only to do
with the fact of
my own personal preferences but also
because
uh we're we are living in a time where
okay so i don't know if you believe in
social i'm sure you do believe in social
contract so these societies that were
developed back in
the past in muslim societies had these
rules already structured in their
societies that everyone already agreed
to that you can't do this
okay and um this was part of it wasn't
it
it wasn't something that had to be
imposed upon other societies around them
so uh for example the byzantines were
always busy slandering
you know the profit every chance they
got but it's not like they were sending
assassins into byzantine empire and like
killing these people
okay because it wasn't happening within
their own polity
all right so that's one thing um uh so
the whole thing that happened with like
charlie hebdo was completely outside the
bounds of even
what classical scholars i think would
have allowed okay because there was no
there's nothing i mean that was just
like
like these guys are in a completely
different place in time like you know
they're they're doing their own thing in
their own country
this is their own opinions and you just
randomly come from like somewhere and
just go in and start murdering these
people
you know it's just like that that there
was no there was no even agreement to
begin with between
what they could or could not say like it
was completely unjust
from both a legal standpoint islamic
legal standpoint
and and even just within the context of
what they were doing
so you know i think that's the reason
that majority of scholars and the
majority of muslims in the world
condemned it
um but if you want to talk about like
absolute free speech
i mean there's no such thing even in any
society you live in the uk
for example i'm sure you already know
this
there's only one country in the world
that has any sort of absolute free
speech
except for libel and slander and that's
probably the united states
as far as i'm aware though i could be an
exceptionalist right now
i mean sorry sorry just one point you
said slander but you i mean once
someone is dead or passed away you can't
you know it's irrelevant but what you
say like if i were to sign an island
napoleon
or caesar or any other major leader of
the past it doesn't make it
you know it doesn't make a difference so
why is muhammad different
according to islamic scriptures like
like i said he's the prophet of allah
he's god's i mean
right there's an obvious divine
difference there
i mean if you want to talk just within
the islamic
yeah but i mean from a from a practical
point of view
if someone's talking about if you want
to talk outside islam
like i guess i mean let's say for
example you live in a are not you
and someone lives in an islamic country
or as a muslim majority country
um whether it's something as saudi
arabia or malaysia or pakistan
take your pick doesn't really matter um
you know should anyone be allowed to
like for example draw a cartoon of the
prophet muhammad even if it's in a
non-provocative way when i was in
heights
in hyde park i even said to muslims if i
draw muhammad
sitting on a park bench no you can't do
that
i'm like i'm not even trying to like i'm
not even like drawing a crude
racialized vulgar you know whatever
there should be a distinction between
you know some sort of innocuous
presentation versus whatever any sort of
crude
you know you know obviously and i think
the classical scholars would have done
so as well
um you know there's a difference between
say idolizing or making an idol of
something versus
making a direct insult of that
particular figure so
even then there would have been the
demarcation that said
you know i i'm gonna be frank with you i
think that any society that comes up
with that rule
has a right to it but that's that's just
there if everyone agrees
any society that comes up with the rule
of what so what's the rule if they want
to
to restrict a particular form of speech
within their society they have
a right to do so i mean that's
kind of just arbitrary isn't it it's not
really really arbitrary i mean the thing
is
that what constitutes for example so
what constitutes as
slander and libel or insult or mocking
is also arbitrary
is it not yeah which is why the best
solution
is you do not impose that rule upon
everyone else
except upon who it is agreed upon within
their own societal structure
no the best solution is to not have that
rule in the first place because
what defines what is offensive i i may i
i don't actually believe this but
i might i don't know but someone might
read the quran and say i find this verse
talking about gay people or jews or
whatever it is very offensive
now you can say now you can say but you
haven't read the context you haven't
read
and they say well i'm sorry this is how
i understand it but i could draw a
cartoon to profit
and you you might find it offensive or
someone out there
someone someone out there someone out
there will might find it offensive and i
can say
but you know you you don't understand my
content i'm i'm a satirist it's my job
to make fun of people
no no no this is offensive now
that's subjective what is offensive so
if you're going to base a rule
on something which is blatantly
subjective i mean of course all
there is a level of subject subjectivity
in most laws or whatever i get that
you know why is the age of consent uh
consensus 16 and not
17 or what whatever i understand that
but something as
simple as taking offense which is you
know even
three brothers in the same family will
not get offended at the same thing
okay and you're now you're going to make
that into a law
and then the pun and then you're gonna
attach a punishment for that law which
is a very severe thing it's one thing to
say
maybe you shouldn't do it it's another
thing to say if you do do it
that is a punishment and unfortunately
of course i'm not saying pakistan is the
role model islamic country by any
stretch
but in countries like pakistan and
others like it you know blasphemy
is a very serious and you can get into
like death
like life and death situations for
uttering the wrong word or saying
something in the wrong way
um i mean i i'm not even talking about
making fun of islam
i'm talking about people that have said
things against
a particular companion of the prophet or
the prophet's wife and that's
blasphemous
so the whole thing too about offense um
i think we're
not in agreement of what that means
actually offense is not simply
for example my understanding of offense
is not simply like
something you feel bad about you know
what i mean so for example we're talking
about offending
the prophet's honor i'm not saying the
prophet is going to be like
how dare you you look because he's dead
you know i mean like he's not going to
feel that
you know what i mean um i think it has
more to do with
sort of this uh this understanding of
reputation and honor that sort of
supersedes any sort of feeling about it
it's sort of like it
is in many ways um see i have a hard
time
differentiating my differentiation but
separating the whole context of offense
and this was
in this regard from like slander and
libel so like
it's hard for me to do that because to
me it's not just
or even the islamic interpretation is
not just simply offending somebody and
making them feel bad because you can do
that with anything
you don't even have to say anything to
offend people that's true like you can
just like you could like just not
do something and offend somebody you
know like you know like opening a door
for women these days some places like
that's offensive
you're right like so i think that there
is has more of a um
it's it's not so much like a uh what's
the word
i'm trying to find out appropriate words
for this
it's not based on feelings so much as it
is based on the content of
the speech and who is it being directed
to so
i mean do you think let's say for
example if the you know if we were alive
in the time of the prophet
and i mocked him or someone wouldn't do
it he probably would not have hurt you
at all
sorry he wouldn't have what sorry he
would have not harmed you in the
slightest
so if he's not going to harm me why
should they why should he use followers
i'm just explaining to you what's going
on no sorry i don't i don't
have a go at you but you're like
i mean this is something which i was
very confused about as a muslim as well
because you hear stories
for you before you go on to mention that
there's they're probably going to be
this thing about like well you know he
harmed poets and stuff like this well
it's like yes
he did under certain circumstances so
for example there would be people who
would like literally go up to his face
and like call him names and he wouldn't
do anything
and then there was this guy there would
be a bunch of people in some other tribe
saying he's horrible poetry about him
and then he would send like an assassin
and they're wondering like okay so
what's the difference here why would he
be offended here
and not offended over here right and
it's like well if you actually read the
story it wasn't just about them
insulting him it was about them like
trying to get people to like go to war
oh yeah yeah so that was the reason why
so that's why
i want to make that very clear that
people so people don't bring that up to
some sort of objection like oh
well he was offended during this time
it's like no he wasn't most of the time
he just like let people talk crap about
him and then he just walked away
okay fair enough so i mean we hear about
they're not
that that that's a fair enough point so
i'm asking you if the prophet
himself you've told me if i were to
insult the prophet to his face and you'd
give an example of poets who
said all sorts of stuff to his face and
his response was
whatever um why would his followers take
it upon themselves whether it be
in vigilante style or by the law uh
in the state level to then punish people
for that for insulting the prophet when
you know he would not have done that
himself so actually you're not following
the sunnah of the prophet if he's saying
if his actions were don't uh retaliate
against
insults and then his followers are like
if you insult the prophet i'm going to
kill you or punish you or find you or
stack you on the wrist whatever it is
how does that make sense yeah no i mean
that's a very good question to be honest
and i think it has a lot to do sorry i'm
looking at something that's fine uh it
has a lot to do with
um like i said it has nothing to do with
so much as personal feelings
as it has to do with sort of trying to
protect the honor and reputation of an
individual as from the scholarly
perspective
so um and i guess you could say even
that the scholars sort of interpreted
uh that offense as also casting like
dishonor upon the entire muslim
community because they took him as an
example so like if you say
x person is a pedophile um and
all of these people claim to be
following this individual
it's sort of almost implicitly stating
that all of these people
are following the example of that
you know what i'm trying to say oh i
understand that but that's neither here
or there
let's say for example i'm giving you i'm
just telling you what their reasoning
would have been
and for them it was also like his
character
and the and the divine decrees and you
know the quran
were actually foundational to the
society itself so
it was almost as though you were
undermining the incomplete
civilizational
values that these people held and for
them that was
that was beyond reproach actually beyond
any sort of like um
uh what is it uh that was just beyond
the pale like you can't do that
um like i said it's up to you whether
you
agree or disagree with this but for me
um
and as far as i'm concerned as long as
these people in the society are not
imposing it upon other civilizations
or respecting other people outside of
their own
societal context to abide by that then
that's their business
so in in short you don't think
to summarize in short um you don't think
from what i understand islam supports
free speech
i don't think any society truly supports
free speech well i mean some do more
than others or free expression well
that's
that's even that even then there's no
absolute just understanding of what that
means i mean if you want like an
absolute understanding of free speech
anybody can say whatever they want ever
no society exists like that
there's no society like that there are
limitations everywhere
again these incitements of violence or
like for example i can't go into court
and start lying and say free speech but
that's a very why but why don't we
why don't we why don't we condemn those
things i mean why do we
condemn what why do we allow those
limitations you know what i mean like if
you actually look deep into these
certain things you go okay well
there are practical reasons why we don't
allow for people to slander and libel or
go into a court and lie etc etc because
you know it causes certain uh detriment
to that society or to the individuals
who it's being
directed to right we kind of imply these
things
but then when it comes to like um other
things within that within a different
societal context where it might harm
them
or might harm their understanding of
these institutions or the individuals
reputations all of a sudden we say well
you know they have more limited free
speech
well it's like okay well maybe from your
particular
societal construct they do but for them
like they can talk about everything else
you know it's not like the problem for
them it's not something they feel any
sort of limitation for um
and so so just from that point you said
that you know for example if i lie in
court
that's different to you know that's
actually
tangible harm because if someone's i
don't know being tried for murder and i
say he didn't do it
but it still hurts people i mean are we
getting
hurt people in the sense you called me
fat i'm hurt no
no no like being like okay so if you
spread a lie about somebody
it doesn't end it doesn't put them in
jail or anything like that but
it it destroys their relationships oh
yeah that can happen i agree but that's
a gossip
but are you gonna punish people for
gossip well actually you can
for life but i mean in in in
if if you've proven slander actually you
can't punish people for gossip
even in the united states um so uh
they're they're certainly okay so let me
let me give you throw an olive branch
here
all right and this is gonna piss off a
lot of people excuse my french
but but speaking of the french right
um the reason that i'm upset at france
for
banning hijab and things like this has
nothing to do with
with freedom of expression
or freedom of this or freedom of that
that's their own business i don't care
what sort of rules they implement in
their own society they don't want to
have hijab in their society that's their
business and i feel that muslims have a
right to leave
okay um you know the reason that i that
i feel that france is being
this way is because i think it has a
very um
i think it's being hypocritical to what
their own stated standards are
and i feel that that they are unjustly
going after one particular group
yeah i would agree with that also okay
so but i wouldn't say i wouldn't i
wouldn't condemn
france for being like you know we want
all our women not to wear head scarves
that's their business you know what i
mean but
i understand i don't understand this
is their business therefore i mean if
there was a country that you know
was that had a savage practice of
killing you know
i don't know the the second son of their
family they got
and it's and you say well you know it's
okay it's their country
you can disagree with it all you want
that's fine but there's a difference
between disagreeing and then forcing
those people to change
so for example one of the reasons that i
have such a problem with
a lot of these uh universalist
statements by a lot of societies with
respect to what other societies do like
muslim societies do
right one of the reasons i have such a
problem with it is because they've been
used as an excuse to
to completely obliterate those countries
what do you mean like for example iraq
like yes the first lie was that they had
weapons of mass destruction
but after that was exposed the next
argument was
was worse i don't know if you're
familiar with the with the discourse
around the iraq war
but it was basically like we need to
free these people
oh yeah yeah you know that was basically
the argument in a nutshell we need to
free them from their own values
i mean that was just a cover for the
mistake oh yeah it is but it was just
but that's how people actually justified
it i'm not even joking like that's how
the people didn't look at it as some
sort of illusion like they literally
believe this is a good thing to do
you know and that was that's one of the
reasons that i hate a lot of these talks
about
you know what other countries should be
doing about their laws and blah blah
blah it's like okay
to what point do you disagree that
you're going to force them to change
if they all for example if let me let me
give you a
one say everyone agrees in a muslim
country that you should chop the hand
off
for thievery okay and you don't agree
with it right because your values don't
allow you to think that that's okay okay
right
at what point do you say those people
can do what they want
and at what point do you say we need to
go there and bomb them and slaughter
half their population to get them to
change
oh i would i i would consider myself a
libertarian so i'm competing against
violence in the first place
or or even put like uh sanctions on them
and these are all people that agree with
this punishment okay it's not like
they're
they're all oppressed by their own
agreement like they all they all think
it's okay to do this
i mean if you're asking me as an
individual i would say the best way to
uh change their mind is to have
discourse is to talk to them and free
speech
that's fine we can have discourse and
things like this right but the problem
is when you start to try to impose your
values upon other societies and that's
the point i'm trying to get across so
say a muslim society has these
particular rules
as long as they're not forcing say
france or europe or europe in general to
follow their standards
i don't i honestly you know what they do
in their country that's between them
okay and likewise what france does in
its country as long as it's not
forcing other well they do force other
people around the world to be honest but
that's a different discussion
you know so yeah then you know they can
do what they want and i think the
muslims
that are living in france right now are
being oppressed because these rules are
just being injured
or just being introduced now just for
the sake of oppressing that particular
group of people
it has nothing to do with free speech or
expression just because they want to
force these people to conform to their
values after they've lived there
for so long you know so there's a level
of injustice there that
that i feel is is is not even warranted
in the basis of social contract
because the people who were initially
there to begin with who never had these
rules are now being forced to follow
them
you know when they they moved into this
country knowing that
that wasn't the case before you know
it's kind of like a bait and switch
right that's not fair you know what i
mean
um so that's one of the reasons i don't
like france right now is because they're
so hypocrite i don't like france in
general i never liked it
so and that's probably because i'm also
american but
uh and spanish that's two combinations
of people who don't like
yes so um
but anyways fair enough so i'm gonna we
were speaking for maybe like an hour and
a half now so i'm gonna take a question
realize that
yes time has flown past um i'm gonna
take questions from the comment section
because i know
everyone here has been very patient i've
got tons of comments some of the
questions for you absolutely you're a
very popular man right now
and so i'm going to go for hang on a
second let me see some questions
uh islamic morals how do they make sense
uh like islamic talaq law that's the
divorce law
or not being able to marry your foster
sister
or men not wearing gold
okay because i actually went to a muslim
school and um i remember
the the islamic teacher said that it's
not permissible for men to wear gold
i was like what i don't get it why
so if you if you've got any gold chains
underneath that shirt of yours you want
to show that
no no i don't so i mean so so things
like that how would you
make sense of that there are some ritual
preferences
within the sorry within the thick there
are certain ritualistic preferences that
are
stipulated in the quran and the fick
that have no uh practical value outside
of the fact that allah wants you to do
them
to be honest that's how many scholars
have regarded too like for instance the
whole pork thing it's like
there is no they didn't say allah didn't
say you can't eat pork because it's
unhealthy
you know it just he just doesn't want
you to eat it so it's uh
just preference it's kind of like a test
it's like a test
of of following and in order to
demarcate between other societies
that's really it so there are certain
rituals like for instance there's no
there's no health benefits behind prayer
actually i want one could argue that
there are but i mean well
you know well i guess you could say
psychologically yeah okay there's no
physical you know but i can also argue
psychologically it's good to follow
these rules because you know it gives
you a sense of purpose and
you know but you know that's like that's
not really the purpose that it would
be i see you saying yeah i mean so like
there are certain things like even
wearing the headscarf
like that's a form of modesty that's
what it says in the quran but it doesn't
go beyond
like that's that general understanding
like there's a lot of people now who are
saying like hair is like attractive like
no that's not it
it's like it has nothing to do with it
because the hair was attractive you know
what i mean like
um it's because they wanted to demarcate
between
other societies who are not veiling or
covering themselves appropriately
and uh of course there are there is some
level of sexuality involved in that
the same thing with men wearing not
having to wear like super super tight
shirts and things like this you know
or or things like that so
that's a very interesting point uh i
actually respect you for saying that
because normally we hear the opposite
like oh
there's i actually remember this uh in
uh the uh would you want to call it when
i was in islamic school
one of the teachers i can't believe it
was a teacher or student so that said
that there's a scientific reason why men
shouldn't wear gold it's because of the
chemical reaction between their
skin and nonsense sorry that's nonsense
right exactly but this is what i'm
trying to say is that they went to that
extent to try and justify
uh this uh rule or whatever but you're
just clearly saying
it's just rules don't don't have any
particular
like practical hook them behind them
they're just there
you know they might be just for the sake
of demarcating between other religious
communities
it might be just for the sake of testing
people like the scholars have even
differentiated between
things that have practical value versus
those that don't you know
they're just there for the purpose of
following i mean
something like uh the uh three devote
like when you say
i divorce you i divorce you i divorce
you three times
i mean that is not simply a preference
like
goals i want to make sure that excuse me
that
you know there was divorce wasn't this
easy thing
and uh that you could just like do you
know like just immediately you think
about it first you have chances you know
what i mean don't just give up on your
wife
because you know she made you angry or
something like that's not how you should
treat divorce
um you know and and there are a lot of
rules even in the quran that
try to mitigate a lot of abuses towards
people
you know i mean that were actually
occurring in that society at the time
a lot of horrible abuses um
so um there are several examples even
with regard to slaves you know what i
mean like
looking at you know there are a lot of
pastors in the quran to say treat your
slave well
you're thinking like why would it say
this it's like because you know how
trans the slaves were treated back then
was horrible
you know they would just like treat them
like they were nothing they were just
cattle
right yeah and until the quran came and
revealed these things like look if
you're going to have a slave if you have
a slave
you know treat them nicely don't hurt
them don't beat them don't do these
horrible things and if they ask you for
to be free and you see good character in
them then let them go free
give them some of your wealth even and
let them know
so sure sure uh just a
a couple of things first on the on the
divorce thing um
from what from what i understand when i
was in the islamic school it's even if
it's not even like
let's say for example i get into arguing
my wife and i say divorcing towards
yourself
it's not even like in that moment let's
say i am married to her over a 10-year
period and i
say over that 10-year period i divorced
you then two years later i divorced you
again and then ten years five years
later i said i divorce you again
that still counts as one it counts
it counts in the fix if it's been
registered
if it's registered what does that mean
is it not going to be like
like yeah because the thing is that the
courts are the only ones that can really
verify whether the person has i mean
from what i understand that's a general
rule but it's a general rule
that you shouldn't do that but i mean
like these people have this like
absolutist understanding that oh
you know i was in the privacy of my home
and i said three times and because i was
angry and then you know some scholars
would took it really seriously
and then a lot of other scholars were
kind of like well you know
it also bases on your intention and you
didn't even register i mean you didn't
go to a potty or anything
so it's like it's not really there just
you know makeup and
and just don't do it again
would the wife have the same right of
the husband like wife has a right over
the husband in terms of whether or not
he's fulfilling her duties
but not the right to divorce in the same
manner not the right to divorce in the
same manner
why because she's not the one
financially
she's not the one um so let me put it
this way so the guy
right he's the one supporting her
financially completely
okay he's the one who's who after the
divorce occurs he has to give her
alimony
and chase child support and everything
else you know if she's divorced
for her to divorce him she has to have
some sort of like
uh what is it uh
reason beyond simply like oh i don't
like him
you know what i mean because there's no
real repercussions for her
in the event that the divorce occurs
but i mean that's interesting because i
believe that the prophet was employed by
his wife who earned more
money than him but if she said well i'm
actually supporting you
because i'm i've employed you and that's
just then then oh well that's the
interesting thing that's lovely that you
brought it up because in the thick
if it's the woman who's supporting the
guy then he actually loses all rights to
her and she has a right to divorce him
at any point in time
right because the thing is that within
the islamic legal structure
what happens is that the guy has to do
certain things right he has to support
her he has to maintain her he has to do
this this this and that right
he can't beat her you can't do all these
horrible things right because if she
does
then she can go to a party and then they
could just that's it done
call us marriage is over okay like she
can just do that like that
very easily however um he has more of
like an ease to kind of divorce her even
if he doesn't like her
uh because there's not really any
repercussions she just gets all the
money
she still gets everything from him after
that happens so he's actually hurting
himself more
by doing so uh so that was kind of like
the reasoning behind all of that
fair enough so i want to ask a different
question here someone said regarding
apostasy
law argued that it is moral
within sharia law that an atheist gets
executed because him believing
so him being vocal minimizes the
happiness
of the majority of muslims i never said
that at all that's a strong manner
slander
i mean i think you're referring to
daniel hakika
so unless you have someone else you can
go do that
but do you agree with that statement he
made
no i don't agree with that statement
anyway so he said nothing about
minimizing maximizing happiness that's
why it has nothing to do with that i
don't even agree with the whole entire
understanding of how laws are formulated
why
so i mean would you be uh
from your understanding do you think
it's moral or islamic whatever you want
to call it
uh to execute someone for leaving their
religion
do i think it's moral in the
contemporary
context now okay so
do you think do do you think it's moral
like i think
i yeah yeah yeah you like no no
islamically what's the position on that
oh it depends on whether or not you're
an imperial society
i brought this up in a former
conversation with army naval and others
in ali
you know the whole thing the whole
purpose behind the apostasy law in the
past was that your
religion was tied to your citizenship
and there was a constant state of war
around you so
if you abandoned that religion it was
like as though you were committing
treason by joining the other side
um and even then that law was not always
implemented
back then either the prophet saws
sometimes let people go
if he didn't think he didn't see them as
a threat so
in the fick it is determined that if
somebody leaves their faith
that they should be killed however that
fake was developed within the context of
the imperial state
as that started to sort of like dwindle
the imperial estate started the dwindle
scholars started to change their
interpretations
of not only both the apostasy laws but
also in terms of how warfare should be
conducted so for example there are a lot
of scholars within the 20th
21st century even prior to the fall of
the ottoman empire
that we're starting to develop these
positions saying well the
empire's nation states are starting to
become more popular
so how do we determine apostasy in in
in a state that is no longer not only
imperialistic but
that doesn't define its citizenship
based on its religious values
so these discussions going back and
forth some people a lot of people
disagree with me
there are some even muslims that i've
had to argue with respect to this
but it's actually a very common position
especially in academia and if you look
at for example uh jonathan brown's work
on the subject matter
uh he develops this this argument as
well he's a hadith scholar
at georgetown university and you can
read his work at the king institute
so they saw your religion as
as your sort of citizenship is something
like that so for example that's like
you know they did even the byzantines
saw christianity as a form there i mean
thomas aquinas was one of the first to
formulate
apostasy laws and punishments for the
christian nations
i mean like this was everywhere it
wasn't like
the muslims just randomly came up with
it one day you know um
so this this this this was a very common
position to take during imperial
times uh at least in the classical
imperial age
would you not just count that as treason
i mean like for example if i leave islam
but i
am still uh following the laws of the
land i don't want
some sort of insurrection or rebellion
within the laws of the land
they would interpret it as though if you
didn't like if you didn't like
like they didn't see like a lot of
scholars didn't see a point in you like
publicizing it to the world if that was
the case like you would just kind of
like
find your own business leave you know i
mean don't you know
for them it was like sort of a
declaration
that you were willing to fight the state
now they didn't always take it that way
that was the general rule
but they usually sometimes they give
exceptions to people they would just let
them leave you know what i mean but
so it's not it's not as black and white
as people put it
but i mean would you what is your
position i mean
now would you categorize categorically
deny or say no
it may have some use well it would
depend if the conditions returned
but they haven't we're not even in that
we're not even in that but it's
impossible to even resurrect those
those uh the structure of that of that
uh
i mean it's like we just there's no
conditions that would allow that to
occur now
you see what i'm trying to say uh i
understand it so it doesn't
yeah it's the same thing with like
marrying nine-year-old girls there's no
the conditions right now do not allow
for that to occur
see so so on the on the question of nine
year old girls i understand that you
know
we were talking about talking about
before on a biological level or even on
a societal level
children was again rightly or wrong they
were in one second i'm sorry draymond
revert ali mentioned a kuffar academic
nice move jonathan brown is a convert to
islam
so piss off yeah yeah he's he's muslim
anyways move on sorry yeah that's fine
it's fine
so yeah um i was saying that with
regards to aisha being nine
i mean i i this is gonna sound it might
sound strange i don't think
she was actually nine and i'm saying
this as a non-muslim not because i'm
trying to save the honor of the prophet
but because i
i've heard different arguments but even
if you were to assume she was nine
um just because
people did things back in those days
which they saw as acceptable or
practical even
and they may have had some
justifications for marrying a
nine-year-old ten-year-old because
they live that long and they live a
different lifestyle whatever it is
i mean this is going back to what i was
saying too early about
um if you beat your child when they're
young you can actually scientifically
prove with the data and stats whatever
it is
this is bad for them because of the
whatever
they have said the same thing that
there's a part of your brain that hasn't
even developed
when you're that young or even until the
age of i think i think again i think it
was a dr phil
right now on age of 17 or 18 a part of
your
brain has not developed so you cannot
you don't necessarily understand
the future consequences of your present
actions
and especially when it comes to
consenting in marriage
forget about this we could talk about
sex as well the actual
consent to your marriage at that young
of
that young of an age where you are you
don't even know you don't even know
anything about life because you haven't
only lived
nine years most of you would in in the
sort of uh
lap or the sort of arms of your mother
or father how on earth can a nine year
old even
understand foresee comprehend something
like
marriage and well i think that you're
not uh no offense i don't think you've
read the um
bioarchaeology of children i mean uh
behave psychosocially and biologically
children have developed much differently
over time
uh even in the contemporary period it's
just it's remarkably different
if you read previous studies i mean my
my paper is coming out i want to get too
much detail
i have a paper coming out of it very
soon from the king institute that shows
all of that scientific evidence
that shows that people back then were
definitely very very different
especially even in their younger years
they were far more mature or prepared to
to accept that sort of lifestyle
so i want to deal with some of the
people in your comment section just for
fun if you don't mind
sean
let's see who am i going to pick on
all right oh oh stop spamming is in
there that's interesting
you know i found it really fascinating
when you uh when you had a discussion
with him
because um this is one of the things
that i have a problem with we talked
earlier about
um about the whole internet uh culture
and how
knowledge is perceived and things like
this um
you know i think he i had some run-ins
with him in the past
and it's interesting how he claims that
his entire channels were taken down
because you know
muslims are are trying to take him down
and because youtube is being run by
muslims and things like this
it's conspiratorial sort of things um
you know but it's like it's like this
sort of
these very trite and juvenile opinions
about islam
masked as this like respective dialogue
when you're constantly harassing people
and making sock accounts to insult them
you know this is the reason that a lot
of people can't have the sort of
discussions that we're having today
is because of these individuals sort of
coming under the
the guise of respect dialogue and
intellectual discourse
um and you know and you know you know
what else is really interesting you and
i are sitting here
and we are having a discussion showing
our faces
in front of the world uh without any
sort of animosity between you or i
and yet a lot of the people who who
who constantly uh keep you know
bashing on islam and and muslims about
not having you know intellectualism or
free speech and all this stuff um you
know they are always the ones to hide
themselves and their behaviors and their
characters behind a computer screen
you know and have you know these little
avatars and make all these socket counts
and things like this and i feel that
that's also very
problematic and i say this to muslims as
well you should not do these things
this is not helping the discourse it's
not helping people uh
express themselves in the appropriate
manner to have actual discussions
you know if you want to be a troll
that's fine but don't expect people to
take you seriously
or your call to respectful dialogue if
you're going to act like one
that's okay so sorry yeah
uh so i just want to go after him
because he's really pathetic
and let's see who else so just
just to that point interesting point
about uh not showing her face
i mean i understand that some people um
due to the nature of their work or where
they live
they can't reveal their identity because
it could i don't know
have serious implications uh on to about
their family life or they might get
fired from work or
a whole host of reasons so i understand
that i mean i i do sympathize with that
um but you know one may if i'm being
facetious and please allow me to be
facetious
uh once in a while um
um what if stop spamming is in the copy
that would be funny as hell no but i've
heard his boys actually he sounds like
he sounds like some middle-aged guy
having a nervous breakdown because he
lives
well what if he is a transgendered
because you do get some of them nowadays
you know i mean would you be against
nicaraguan because we don't know
i could speak speaking to a woman well i
think she's a woman but i have no idea
who she is
uh i don't live in malaysia i live in
the us um
so the problem with online anonymity is
that like
you don't have any sort of presence of
the individual so there is no
there is utterly no consequences for
their convictions and what i mean by
that is not
death or anything like this what i mean
is by by personal
um rebuke okay are these individuals
lives being found out i feel like a lot
of these people who hide behind
the internet have less to do with a
woman's reason for hiding her face
i think it has more to do with the fact
that they want to hide their personal
lives because
they're concerned of being found out
about what they're hiding
um see i i like to show myself i have
nothing to hide
you know i mean and i've been threatened
by isis members themselves
okay in person in malaysia when i was
acting out against them
uh by the authority of the of the
malaysian government
i was actually speaking out against i
had them come up to me personally and
threatened to kill me in my family
i've never worn a mask okay so i i see a
lot of these people and i just feel like
they're hiding something else
that said um i mean but
okay i mean what if i mean because i i
remember
uh because i uh especially especially in
britain
things are very politically correct and
if someone were to be saying something
controversial about politics or religion
or whatever it may be
or even feminism on youtube and they got
found out
and it has happened many times where
people have said stuff on youtube or
twitter
and then they get fired from work and
it's completely not because they're not
doing well at their work it's because
well this doesn't look too good and that
therefore they just sort of
uh don't reveal their faces uh or
so i just think a lot of people don't
they just lack conviction if you're
gonna have an opinion just say it
you know if you're worried about what
people are gonna think of you or if
they're going to find out that you work
at some sort of job or something like
you're pathetic
you are pathetic that's as far as i as i
understand that you are pathetic you
have no business talking about free
speech and expression
when you're too scared to even show your
face when you're making an opinion
i'm sorry okay you are
it's very steady words now you are a
pathetic person i lived in malaysia for
almost 10 years
i was threatened by extremists
themselves i was even i was even almost
assaulted a few times and i never ever
ever had the urge to hide my face and
here we are we got a bunch of masked
morons online who have no education
whatsoever
and who are just blasting out their
opinions like nothing who think that
they're so
brave you guys are pathetic losers who
would not stand
one day fighting for anything
even your own balls okay you would have
them cut off to hide your
face you were pathetic
well um i'm done i'm done
you certainly don't miss your words on
that uh
in case you missed that guys you're
pathetic
yeah it's true no i'm sorry it's true
it's so true
these are not men these are a bunch of
beta males hiding behind the computer
because they're scared mommy and daddy's
gonna find out
okay that's it that's all it is
wow and i'm happy about it to say that i
wanted to say that for a long time
you deserve it i don't care
i'm happy that you know you uh
found this channel to you know extremely
express your views
i think it's great i i actually prefer
this more i'm not gonna lie
this this is this is a guy that i can
get on with oh they hide because muslims
like it nobody wants to kill you you are
irrelevant
you're some random guy on the internet
nobody wants to kill you
my my sheikh sheikh omar suleiman has
been personally listed on the hit list
of isis
okay nobody's gonna be oh alvin prakesh
or tom clements or all these other
idiots dna598 oh we need to go kill them
because you know they're making fun of
islam on the internet
you guys are nothing literally nothing
what the hell okay so um just
uh i mean there have been cases where
you know
some people in bangladesh bloggers oh no
you want to talk about bangladesh we
can't go fine
so listen sarah hater and all these
other people
always keep talking about like you know
all these
these bloggers they're writing stuff
about islam in there well by the way
they're more brave than these people
because at least they show their faces
you know oh they're writing about islam
so they're getting killed you know
because they're criticizing islam
you don't know a half of it have you
ever read the story about some of these
bloggers i'm not justifying it by the
way i want to be very clear here they
were murdered they were murdered
okay it was unjust what happened to them
but they weren't killed because they
were criticizing islam
they were killed because on their own
blogs and these are every single one of
these bloggers or at least the majority
of them
all right they called for this movement
this protest
movie called shabac okay i don't know if
you're familiar with it
and the shabbat movement was calling on
the government run by a secular
uh uh uh secular party
run by a woman also by the way so that's
not very fundamentalist
okay um and basically
um this party and sheikh hasina came up
with this rule
these trumped up charges that okay we're
gonna start charging people for what
happened in the 1970s for some
independence war
and we're going to execute these people
okay and
uh they started to go after islamist
leaders in the country the the
opposition party so
these secular bloggers called for this
movement where they were openly calling
for the execution
prosecution and execution of islamist
leaders in the country
it was after that that some of these
people within that group
decided to kill them it wasn't because
they were criticizing islam that's
nonsense
okay and especially since the majority
of the islamists in the country had
counter protest
and did not commit any violence at all
so i'm sorry i'm not trying to i don't
want to say that these people deserve to
die but what i want to say is that it's
a ridiculous myth
that they're just being hunted down
randomly because they happen to
criticize they were criticizing islam
before they were killed that nobody
cared
until they joined that movement and
started calling for the execution of
islamist leaders in the country
so i wish people we stopped talking like
this it had nothing to do with them
they were trying to get other people
killed okay
like this is not cool like you know like
this is not you shouldn't be lionizing
these people
they have problems too like that's just
not cool to be to be making it out to be
like that
okay so uh i i don't know too much about
about the bandits you broke up so i
i'm just gonna leave that um can i ask a
strange question
uh please go oh i'm right out of breath
conspiracy like look at the news for
god's sake research it don't start just
looking at wikipedia
or listening what some of these other
ex-muslims are saying about it okay
actually research what happened you will
find everything i just said was correct
it's in the new york times for god's
sake it's like so what about um
the guy in pakistan in university i mean
that was tragic what happened to him i
mean yeah no that was tragic it was
tragic
i'm just saying the majority of these
people who have been hunted down and
killed by these
these crazies okay is because it has
nothing to do with them criticizing
all right i'm just telling you like
there are there is more stuff going on
here
that meets the eye it's not that black
and white and that's all i'm trying to
say is like you want to condemn these
people
for killing for murdering people then
fine please do so it was immoral
okay but stop making it out this
narrative where it's just like oh you
know one day some guy was just like i
don't agree with islam and i just got
killed
that's not what happened but i mean
surely you recognize that there is a
risk when someone does criticize this
farm within a muslim majority country
no not all of them i mean obviously not
all not every single person but i mean
like there is a substantial
even not even all the countries i mean
there's like you know i've known
ex-muslims in malaysia who are openly
criticizing even in malaysia kinney
which is like this very famous uh online
publication
and like nothing ever happened to them i
mean like i said it's it's because it's
so overblown it's come to this like
mythological
like story like there's a massive
epidemic against ex-muslims and
everyone's going around
all the muslims are foaming at the mouth
waiting to kill everyone that criticizes
it's like no i mean
what about like uh michelle khan
definitely got
yeah like i think that what happened to
him was even though i don't even know
the details behind that entirely
yeah but the thing is like i think that
that was wrong and i'm telling you right
now
even what happened to the bangladeshi
bloggers was wrong
oh yeah i'm not saying i agree i'm not
saying you think it's right to just
get up and kill someone because you
whatever yeah i'm saying that the reason
why
that is like you can look up what i'm
telling you right now there's a lot more
behind these stories than just
you know uh you know like just people
saying stuff and then someone getting
killed
okay okay there's a lot more to it yeah
well i i understand that
but what i'm trying to say is that you
know there is certainly a risk when it
comes to criticizing or mocking or even
even as a muslim if you criticize islam
i mean even as a muslim if you criticize
a particular kind of islam yeah i think
i think that there's a i think there's a
there's a danger mostly of jailing in in
certain countries like pakistan
i mean real estate
i have no doubt about that but like you
know if you're going to
i think it's really ridiculous when a
lot of people make it out to be like
every
muslim country is like it's like no it
isn't like there is so much stuff going
on like
you're more likely to be thrown in jail
in malaysia for criticizing the king
than you
are for criticizing islam i mean like
that just that's just the fact
you know and and the thing is like you
know you hear these ridiculous one-sided
you know very black and white opinions
this nonsense
um well i would say in pakistan you're
more likely to be killed
if you criticize or make fun of islam
i'm not i'm not doubtful about about
certain places i'm just saying
i mean i'm from pakistan but
unfortunately if you want to make an
argument for example i'm going to tell
people if you're going to make an
argument
about apostasy laws right it would
better be focused on pakistan
would for example bangladesh where by
the way the people who murdered those
bloggers were also sentenced to prison
and then executed
by the state so it's like what are you
trying to say that bangladesh supports
murdering
bloggers but at the same time the
government kills the people who murdered
them
that makes no sense um
i'm not saying that the government asked
these people to kill the bloggers i'm
saying there is an environment
unfortunately or an atmosphere where
it's very difficult to criticize islam
so even if the government says you know
don't kill these people
unfortunately there is an even a small
minority but that is a
empowered minority or a stimulated
minority that does take things into
their own hands and which is why
the original debate was about anonymity
if some people um
maybe talk about stop spamming but it
could be anyone who is uh
making videos or criticizing or writing
even uh not even necessarily videos but
they're not showing their face
it could be for a whole host of reasons
and given
the climate within some muslim countries
i it might be a wise thing not to show
your face uh i mean
someone mentioned rafe by the way well
let's let's argue that that's the case
right
okay tell me all the people who are
currently hiding their faces the popular
ex-muslims online
where are they because they're not in
pakistan they're not in saudi arabia
they're not in iraq
they're in like the uk and in america
and you know they're just what they're
doing is they're playing off this
sentiment that all these muslims want to
kill them
okay they're playing off the bigoted
sentiments that majority of muslims are
hunting them down as we speak
because they make youtube videos i mean
that is just [__]
what i would say to that is that um some
ex-muslims
uh in non-muslim countries have
unfortunately
been shunned or on some level uh even
violently uh what you want to call it
have had some sort of violence
act towards them uh because of their
apostasy i remember that i was watching
a story of this somalian guy and i think
it was america
remember now where he went back home he
tried to
reconcile with his family and the men in
his family i think he was from the
somali background
they took him downstairs to the uh
whatever
yeah whatever and surrounded him and
what i want to beat him up whatever it
was
uh it uh i does happen happens it does
happen i'm not saying it doesn't
what i'm trying to argue against and
people don't understand what i'm saying
is that there's no this looks like this
massive epidemic
okay like i think i can find more people
killed in road rage and i can keep for
people killed just because they're
apostates no offense
and i'm not trying to say that that
somehow makes it less of a problem but
what i am saying is that
people have blown it up to such an
extent that now it's like
you know every muslim they talk to they
got to be careful because you know
though they might kill them or something
it's like come on bro
this is really getting ridiculous i i i
agree with you on that i don't think
any muslim you talk to oh my god you
know they've got a knife in the back
pocket and they're going to stab you the
moment you say you're an apostate i i
don't think that is true
um however i mean i'm going to keep
going back to pakistan because you know
it really is a
i mean for example we've got a question
as saying um how can
allah sorry how can how can muslims
combat the extremists among them
like those who glorified the murder of
salman
are you familiar with that case in
pakistan yeah i'm familiar with it
yeah so for example the murderer got a
massive how can muslims deal with this
how can
the majority of muslims combat these
issues
or even the muslims in pakistan i mean
forget about the majority outside
pakistan
if you're a muslim yeah i would say
first off that
that we have to understand that the
extremists that are operating
in these countries right now who are
going around doing these things and
killing people
okay they're just as much of a threat to
an ex-muslim as they are to
regular muslims around them um
and and i think that that needs to be
understood that there is a reason a
motivation that a lot of muslims should
be
sending up and saying something not
simply because they're targeting
explicitly because they're also being
targeted themselves
um and um and i would say about anything
and this has been proven right now even
in a lot of contemporary studies is that
the more islamic education you have uh
and the more that you
appeal to traditional uh sources and
things like this the more likely you are
to help convince others not to do these
things
and i also think that's from the
ideological perspective and then you
have also of course other things that
need to be dealt with
in terms of like counter-terrorism stuff
so for example when you talk about
pakistan and i have proof for this by
the way
so i hope the trolls and the uh in the
chat
can deal with it i i don't think they
can i think they're going to kill
themselves
uh so there's a recent study a research
note on a case study in pakistan that
proved
that the more that somebody has been
inducted in madrasa education the less
likely there to support extremist groups
in the country
um so for example very interesting
because i was watching that documentary
netflix uh
let me tell you let me tell you what the
studies is you guys can look it up
yourself
okay um so
here we go can knowledge of islam
explain lack of support for terrorism
evidence from pakistan from ten
f online dot com um basically they found
that
uh among the population there that they
surveyed they found that there was less
support for extremist organizations
in the country and less support for
terrorism in general
uh the more knowledge of islam that they
had
um the less that they had and the less
educated they had in the religion itself
the more likely they were to join these
organizations
there are also several other studies in
the past year and prior to that
showing the same case for isis members
written and studied i'm sorry studied
and written by the united states armed
forces
uh and i can provide all of these later
if you want you can put in the
description box it's up to you
i would also say um there are many
well-read educated scholars or people
who have studied islam who do believe
apostasy laws
who uh there was that guy in pakist
documentary about him who he's basically
an extremist and he's a recognized
extremist but
very uh well-read uh he's a uh someone
who's uh got a lot of uh but you would
call it knowledge whatever you want to
call it
and of course when you look at the
people in saudi and
medina university and all these people i
mean they would say that you know they
have
islamic knowledge and traditional uh
traditional
traditional knowledge but they still
believe apostates should be killed and
all the rest of it all the other things
that you
maybe you don't even agree with they do
agree with and they certainly uphold
so i mean what would you say with that
well who are these people so for example
if you look at
saudi scholars or people that you know
agree with apostasy laws and
all these different things that even you
wouldn't agree with necessarily
they would say you know what scholars in
particular i mean and what
in what context do they agree with them
so for example i would say i agree with
it within certain conditions
but i would say that i agree with it in
for example in a contemporary period
if someone from a learning position
islam said that they would agree with it
in contempt
period okay
is that not a problem yeah it's
considered a problematic and
something that we can disagree with but
we also looking at whether
does the ideology lead to praxis and i
think that's one of the biggest issues
that i have
and um like i said no study has has
revealed that that's the case
that's why also i laugh about these
little surveys from um
from pew regarding like people's
opinions about
what sharia is and how it should be
implemented it's like okay so what
it's like you know there you know how
many people in the united states it's
okay to kill innocent people overseas
like over 52 percent of the population
and it's like you know you don't you
don't see them walking around murdering
people as a result of that
so like i said there's a difference
between ideological standards and praxis
and that's something that people don't
seem to comprehend very well
okay um so let's get to some more
questions
what do you think of mufti abu leith i
don't like him
why no i don't like it's not that i
don't know him personally i just don't
think i think he's extremely
he has this methodology where he tries
to choose minority opinions or
everything else
in order to make it his whole
methodology is basically like let's make
it as comfortable as possible and i
don't like that i don't think that's the
right way of doing it
um and i and i and i just i feel that
methodology is very
very um there's no validity behind it
i mean he would say that he is referring
to classical texts and classical
scholars
so um yeah he does but
he appeals to only minority opinions
those that have been rejected
by the consensus so do you think he's uh
purposely doing this or is it just a
strange
i mean why do you think he's doing this
why do you think he's doing this in the
minority
i don't necessarily know his intentions
to be honest okay
i think he said something in the past
regarding wanting to make it easy for
people for muslims in the west
or something i don't i don't recall
exactly
where he's coming from but i don't think
his methodology is appropriate
um but that's personally like i don't
know him personally like i can't say
like oh
the guy's a bad guy or something i don't
know who he is
okay um i just want to know how how are
you good for time because uh
just so we can paste it i do i do i
don't have much time left but um
i will say that um you know i can still
keep engaging with the comment section
if you want
yeah so um the whole thing is like okay
so
i want to say is there anything you want
me to answer anything in particular you
want to just look at it
yes i'm just going to pick up some
interesting questions here um someone is
saying
can ali summarize why he believes in
islam
over say christianity or a follower of
thor
or an atheist okay because i used to be
a christian so
uh the reason that i would say islam is
better is because it's more coherent
in terms of the talkida in terms of
how it understands former religions and
things like this so that would be the
general response
um so i've given a very more lengthy
response to why i joined islam became a
follower of islam
in in my story video which you can all
watch
yeah and um can i ask you uh some
some more questions yeah sure so for
example let me give you some more
um before you go on so like here's some
more evidence of
of sort of kind of the idiocy that we
see online
sorry i have to pick on some of your
chat guys so for example
um i have uh i have somebody in here
yeah what is his name abu something okay
great
so i'm basically uh i don't know what
i'm talking about because i can't
pronounce arabic terms
okay that's stupid come on okay yeah
that is pretty stupid
no apparently apparently not
being able to put like to pronounce
things perfectly
uh means that my current phd candidacy
in islamic studies has been overturned
and the guy working retail
who speaks better arabic than me is is
more knowledgeable in subject
yeah so anyways moving on yeah i think i
think i saw a question about how do you
know that
the quran is from god or something like
that i can't wait
uh let me see
so how would you how would you try and
convince someone that the quran is from
god
as opposed to any other scripture or
whatever
oh i would just appeal to the coherency
of the of the narrative and
other things like this i mean this is a
much bigger just there's a much bigger
discussion than
me pointing out like one thing in five
minutes sure
but i mean uh because a lot of people
would say
uh something i i mean i i had trouble
with science and
uh quran i i know we touched on this
earlier but i mean you kind of agree
that we shouldn't do that but a lot
unfortunately a lot a lot of muslims
still play this game
and they say and actually i mean for
example how do you get around a virgin
birth i've really struggled with that
one
with evolution i was like okay maybe it
was possible maybe
with the virgin birth i was like where
did i go with this man how do i
try and reconcile that uh
i mean do you believe in the in the
virgin birth if so how does that
yeah i mean i don't see a problem with
it like you know
i believe in god i believe that allah
you know gave
uh revelation through an illiterate man
so why wouldn't i believe that it's
possible for him to create a you know
a baby in somebody's stomach it's not
like it's not like a big deal for him
to do that that's why i also i was find
it really funny when people always
respond
you believe in flying horses and i'm
like what what you think that's like
hard
for god to do or something i don't get
what the point of the objection was
you know what i mean like i don't get it
like that doesn't make sense to me like
why would i do this
so this is that's a very interesting
point there because
i don't think even me i understand you
know
god can do anything so if he wants to
make a flying horse or if he wants
how is that even ridiculous it's like we
make airplanes and rockets today you're
talking about
the creator of the entire universe and
he can't make like his own thing
like what's why is that a problem
i don't get it sure uh uh i've actually
uh
got uh uh would you want to call it uh
so yeah so it's not the fact that god
you know cannot do it but rather it
rather contradicts
science so i mean science is only
unfortunately unfortunately however
i look at it what's scientific about i
don't understand like what okay so say
okay so
so the whole night journey right that
occurred in
los angeles the flying horse whatever
that's just it just a crude
interpretation of what it could be
you know and then he does it for like
one night i mean how the science can
like verify
something that happened in one event no
but that's the point if i said to you
i saw a guy with two heads oh
forget two heads i i saw i i saw a guy
with a horse and the horse had wings
okay you'd be like that's crazy man come
on
yeah that's what in what context are you
saying it though like so if you told me
that the prophet of god who i already
believe is the prophet of god did this
and it would have been bothering me
i'd be like okay so you're saying that
you suspend your own
scientific well no i mean like we our
beliefs are not entirely dependent
corresponding with any sort of tangible
evidence sometimes our beliefs are
on the basis of whether it coheres with
something that we already believe to be
true
do you see what i'm trying to say i
understand you're saying that's not a
very solid foundation right because
it is that's how we act all the time so
for example have you ever been
up in space no we're seeing the
roundness of the earth
oh you flatter our cow
i'm just saying have you no but we can
but
i mean i haven't physically seen it but
we can use
you haven't physically seen it but
you've determined it based on other
things that cohere with your
understanding of the no but we can use
objective means
math science geometry whatever you want
to call it to verify that it is around
whatever it is but this
there's no direct empirical observation
of the phenomenon occurring
it's the most coherent based on the data
that you have on hand so
that's like me saying i haven't seen my
own brain
therefore i don't have one but we can do
it i would never say that
many people would many people would
believe it or not they're ridiculous
there's no reason to say that yeah i've
never seen my brain so how do i know i
have one
well because it's coherent for you to
believe that you do there's to be
[__] if you said you didn't
like it would just be like you know what
i mean like you don't have to look at
your brain to know that you have one
that's what i'm trying to say that that
people say i don't have certain
empirical facts for example that we
understand are are
primarily based on or underst uh how
much they cohere
to other uh to the data that we have on
hand so for example
we know for for a fact now that um
that the earth rotates around the sun
for example
right but most people have not actually
observed that phenomenon directly
above where they can actually see it we
infer based on
the data being as coherent as possible
bless you and
so so you know it's like that's why i
don't understand is like you want direct
empirical knowledge of everything that
occurs in religion it's like you don't
even do that for yourself
for everything that you're already
considered to be fact you do it based on
what you think is more coherent
sure um i want to make this last point
and then i'll go into something else um
the only thing i would say about that is
that if especially for an extraordinary
claim
which is something we do not observe in
normal day-to-day life which is
like a virgin birth or a flying cause
then you would need a substantial amount
of evidence or
uh yeah basically evidence to back that
claim up
i don't even buy the whole entire thing
about oh extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence that doesn't seem
like a claim that
hasn't evidence there's no unless that
claim itself doesn't have evidence that
makes no sense to me
but i mean did you not think that that
is an extraordinary claim to make
no it depends on like i said the
worldview that you hold
like why would it be extraordinary to
somebody who already believes in god
like doesn't make any sense like he
knows that god can do this
so why why would it be a problem for him
well i mean yeah that's that's right if
god can do whatever you want god can
you know if he can make if he can make a
virgin birth it's like you know you
believe in god it's like at that point
it's like why would you
why do you think it's illogical for him
to be able to snap his
you know just like metaphorically
speaking excuse me yeah
to be able to do something in an instant
you know without without needing
to abide by
uh that said
now i've got a very special request for
you my uh
wife wants to ask you a question are you
okay with that
okay she's been uh she's sitting next to
me uh
if you're not okay with it please let me
know i mean sure i mean i'm not i don't
you know whatever it's completely up to
you i i i don't want to put you on the
spot or anything
okay yeah is that right sure
hang on here this is uh
hi hello i've been like
watching and i've had so many questions
i've been like oh my god there's so much
i wanted to ask you while
and i don't know i don't normally come
on hey
i'm getting double team now no i'm not
gonna say anything i'm not gonna say
anything
no no no i'm i'm uh yeah i'm not gonna
kind of
you know what there's so much i wanted
to ask actually that i've actually
forgotten most of it because like it was
whilst you guys were talking but just on
this topic of talking about like
miracles and things that are happening
out of the blue
this is just a random thing that popped
into my head when you were saying that
though
but why doesn't god like intervene
in other ways like right now like people
starving people dying all around the
world and palestine and
you know in syria you know if he can
just kind of do things and have like a
horse with wings or
have moses kind of split the sea and do
all these kind of amazing things
at that time why isn't why isn't he
doing anything
now we didn't do a lot of things before
either
okay i mean like even during the time of
those miracles he was he was not
he was allowing people to to kill other
people and things like this
i mean what you brought up basically is
the problem of evil so what's the
purpose
okay it's the problem of vehicle fine so
that's the whole another but what's the
yeah
that's that's the whole discussion even
he just brought up that's a whole nother
thing
even prior to even even during the time
that he was doing these miracles and
things like this he was still allowing
other people to die
and to starve i mean it wasn't like he
was he was not
doing anything different no no but that
that's not that's that's not my point
though my point is
if he can intervene and he can kind of
help people
if if god is so loving and so
caring more than we are is what we're
supposed to believe
and i don't think i could watch anything
that's kind of happening in syria and
not
intervene if that's something that i
could do that doesn't make sense
yeah no i understand from a human
perspective that makes sense
but imagine that you could that you
could watch all this you know what's
going on and
you have a lot more knowledge of the
events and then at the end of it all
you know you can redeem it you can just
rectify it instantly
whenever you feel like it like would you
feel any would you feel
the same sentiment i mean like right now
the reason you feel that way is because
you can't do anything about it
oh i don't even understand do you know
what's on the point yeah you don't you
can't do anything about it that's why
you feel that way
but you're talking about a god i would
feel more so if i could do something
about it i'd be like oh i could actually
do something
but i'm not so i knew so if i had a
purpose for evil for existing right
by the way i want to ask you a question
after this as well okay so
i have a purpose for evil existing okay
and i see all these horrible things
happening around me and i know
at the end of the day that all this is
going to be rectified because i've
decided upon it
you know all the people who have
suffered or died they're going to get
justice regardless if it's now or later
i can do it whenever i want okay and i
will do it all right so
how how would i feel okay so if i don't
interview it intervene at this moment
what difference is that gonna make okay
so it's because you've decided so the
justice and the justice system
afterwards is
either you're gonna burn for eternity
and that that's that's
justice is that justice to you for some
people it is yes
but is it for you is it for you oh yeah
it is for me but i want to ask you a
question
you hesitated though because you didn't
answer that question straight away you
said for some people it is
it's not really hesitate or not it's
still an answer the point is is that
is that uh so i want to ask you a
question before we get to the subject of
hell because i find that
a fascinating discussion but um okay so
you see this child starving you see this
woman
being raped you see this person being
murdered and it's over
that's it there is no justice for them
ever they just
die in the way that they are it's an
internal tragedy for the rest
of humanity for the existence of all
existence it has
no purpose whatsoever there is no god
saying he's going to deal with it later
that person suffers and dies in that way
without anything how does that in
comparison to what you are
opposing well that's the thing isn't it
is you want to believe otherwise it's
it's like a coping strategy almost well
if it's okay
okay fine that's fine you're trying to
oppose
my point of view the point of god you're
looking at the problem of evil and
saying okay well god why is he not doing
anything it's like well he will
and then you're and then but your
viewpoint so i'm assuming that you're
not a believer no yeah that's correct
assumption
i'm sorry i just want to make sure that
it's fine
is that you know is that there is
nothing that will happen that person
just that tragedy remains
well always i i'm agnostic to what will
happen what i do know
what i do know is that i don't believe
that
anyone will be punished for eternity or
that kind of that justice system like
that if there is a god
i just think he's so much better than
the idea of
what he is in abrahamic religions or i
mean
i know more about abraham than anything
else so but it's just
it just there's so many petty things as
well that you will
basically go to hell for i mean it just
i mean do you believe that only muslims
are going to be in heaven if you're
muslim you'll go to heaven if you're not
you'll go to hell
yeah you do yeah so like
like a girl in like a village in india
that's hindu which is shirk which is
worse than murder and rape
is gonna burn for eternity because
that's all she knew and that's what she
was brought up doing and that's what
she's doing
okay you're telling me she's ignorant
first off you're telling me she doesn't
have any
okay she knows that no i see it muslims
love to do that so she knows about it
i'm just telling you no no no no i've
heard that before okay so she knows
about islam let's say her next-door
neighbor is a muslim
then she's supposed to be punished for
eternity okay so she learns about islam
and she rejects it
well i mean it's i don't i don't see it
as a rejection but
she's she fully believes in hinduism and
that that fulfills her
so okay well that's that's her business
and then when she gets the judgment day
she needs a law and a law will
basically ask her you know what she did
why she believed that and if she doesn't
submit then of course
yeah i just i just don't see how that
make like in your mind do you ever think
about like
people like just burning in hell fire
like it's just
and like the description of it in the
quran is so intense like
your skin will come off and then your
skin will come back just to be burned
again
and it's not even for like it's eternity
yeah like you're allah is supposed to
love you
like a million times more than your
mother okay and i can't see any mother
doing that to her child it that just
doesn't it doesn't make sense to me like
i don't
think that any anyone could be that
vicious and to be like i need you to
worship me it's a very human
kind of way of um just kind of worship
me tell me i'm amazing tell me how great
i am keep saying it say it five times a
day
well allah says in the quran himself he
doesn't need anybody's worship
um so and yet that's the way to go to
heaven
well yeah because it's for us it's based
on
our that's what purpose for our
existence is to reach a certain point
okay so for example let me let me
okay let me just respond quickly here
okay regarding the whole health thing
hell is not eternal because it's just
eternal per se
i mean quranic scripture is also very
dire uh very specific about this that
okay so i gotta find exact questions
excuse me
so um i will just paraphrase it for you
and then after that you can debate if
you want
okay go ahead so basically it states um
that
the people in the hellfire will ask god
to go back
for a day just so they can get enough
you know
good deeds so they can get into heaven
okay and so they're asking god
if they can go back and then he responds
to them and says i know that when you go
back that you're not going to do that
okay and then you're not going to be
what sorry are you going to be good or
whatever follow his life oh okay i know
you're just saying that because you want
to get out you know when you go back
and he he actually says that he calls
him liars he says that you're not
you're just gonna come back and do the
same thing so i'm keeping you here for
that reason
because i know you're not gonna do it
and uh so the whole like thing about
well
you know they're going there because
they did one thing it's like no well
they're going there because they
continuously refuse
they're in there because they don't stop
that's the problem so it's not like it's
because of one thing they've done and
then
eternally they're punished it's because
they can keep doing it
in they can do it in heaven do what
happen
i don't understand what the why they
keep they keep they keep sinning after
they've died
no they keep refusing to submit so they
go
to what from what i've learned i went to
a muslim school my whole life as well
um what i've learned is that you there
are some people who aren't that bad who
will spend a little bit of time so
there's kind of
different stages so you'll have like a
year or two years or 10 years 20 years
or eternity as like they're like final
like those are the evil people those are
the really bad people who don't submit
they're completely consumed by their
okay there arrogance individuals who
will have it will be punished for a
certain amount of time until they submit
right so but they were created by god
ultimately we are the people we
are because of our genetics because of
our environment
you know you can have totally different
people that you know if
i had twins and i put them in a
different environment they could turn
out totally different it's like
that doesn't make sense to me either for
for that to be judged
oh well now we're dealing with like
determinism and stuff like this okay
yeah there's too many things here i i
understand that there's
i understand the position you're coming
from let me just put it down okay so
i know what you're saying and uh
you know and then there's differences in
terms of compatibility things like this
okay so i don't know which determinist
you are
and i don't want to really get into that
discussion per se but i will say that i
agree with you that to some extent
where we are born and our genetics and
things do play a role in how we are as
people
yeah i will tell you personally and i
believe this
truly not just because it's my own
opinion but i believe that allah is
merciful enough that he will take those
things into account
well that's what i used to believe to be
honest with you when i was a muslim i
was very
very devout and i and i used to just
think well
god is merciful and he he knows better
and
i'll leave it to him and all these
things that generally muslims say
um but and it's funny because i bring
these questions up to muslims all the
time and they always have that answer of
ultimately it's like i don't really know
how to answer it
it's a big question i'm not really going
to go there which is the thing i don't
know how to answer it and i definitely
won't tell you that
that i have the entire like i have some
comprehensive
argument to give you you know i'm not
yeah but i will tell you that
i feel that there is a lot of coherency
behind the answer and i think that it's
that it's often i have actually a
lecture now on my on my
on my channel where i kind of deal with
the problem people from a pragmatic and
psychological perspective and recently
just released a full document uh from
another one of our scholars that you can
read if you want to engage with it in a
more detailed fashion
yeah okay so it was written by a
uh sheikh uh el shanawi anyway so that's
currently gone up and it went up today
so you guys can read it if you want
anyway so yeah i deal with it but you
know my my response to a lot of what you
said in terms of like how evil is
experiencing stuff like this
i do not think i think the world that
you were depicting from the islamic
perspective is a lot
better than the one that is being
depicted from
one without god and i think that i think
that you have a lot more to
answer in terms of like your own world
view
in terms of how to deal with evil and
define evil and even deal with it
from an atheistic perspective than we do
and i'm just being frank
it makes you feel better that's
ultimately what it is it makes you feel
better about the world
that's a very crude way of putting
because i can say the same thing about
morality
and human rights um so let's be friends
let's let's be let's let's not try to
simplify it to that extent because
there's a lot of things that we
that we construct in order to quote
feel good about our the world that we
live in but i would never
define it that way because i think
that's not right um
i didn't understand that last point
about human rights though with regards
to you know like as i mentioned
like for example like human rights don't
exist
uh so why do we have them for some
practical reason right but i'm not going
to sit here and bash it because of that
practical reason
you know what i mean like that that
would be that would be on that would be
what i consider to be
unfair to the actual arguments behind
the pragmatic reasons as to the
existence of those things
okay so you're saying it's the same
thing
religion is just the way it is i'm
saying from a naturalistic perspective
that's what it all amounts to every
human construct
even the whole society you live in is
all a myth
everything you follow is a myth your
moral standards your social constructs
everything is mythological under a
naturalistic perspective there is no
scientific backing to it whatsoever
what do you think
i think we i i would touch on this
earlier that we can derive some
morals from from science so for example
we can scientifically and empirically
prove
hitting someone is wrong killing someone
rape all these things are wrong so i
don't think it's
mythological no no no that's wrong the
thing is
we can say for example that hitting
someone causes a certain
damage to the individual to say that the
damage is wrong or right is not
determined by science but it's as
undesirable to the health of that person
who cares
come on
you're saying that without religion we
wouldn't have so religion is why we have
a moral compass
religion is how we justify it how we
justify oh i see we
justify like human rights okay well i
mean exactly
because without it it's all becomes
arbitrary nonsense i mean
why should the psychopath kill care
about the damage that's being done to
his victims
no i think i think as humans we we have
even animals have
instincts about you know things that are
good and things that are bad there is a
there is a you know there is a natural i
mean i mean
you were saying that earlier that there
is something like if you were to see i
don't know someone suffering for like a
child suffering you would feel something
that was the initial jumping point but
we come up with post hoc
rationalizations for why those natural
inclinations exist well i mean
oh i feel this way therefore it's okay
okay so that's that's an interesting
point so it's a post-hoc thing
but the one thing consistent amongst all
i mean normal human beings is for
example
if a christian a jew a muslim atheist
whatever you want to call it
all saw a child suffering they would all
feel maybe some pain
and or some hurt seeing a child
suffering now they may use their own
religious
or non-religious religious
justifications to come to that
conclusion
nevertheless the one thing that is
consistent amongst all of them is that
they are human
whereas they can maybe use harry they
could read harry potter and say oh harry
potter would never do that they could
read the quran say muhammad would never
do that
but that's their own personal uh
justifications but the one thing
consistent is the fact that they are
human
so i would rather side with some the
stuff that is more consistent rather
than that is
personal or subjective we should be as
consistent as coherent as possible on
the world views
and what i'm trying to say is that if
you adopt a worldview that completely
arbitrates
makes everything arbitrary or makes it
only based on your inclinations
then i think that's a huge problem i
think it's a massive problem because i'm
also justifying my belief in god
sorry i i i'm not sorry justifying
you're also in many ways justifying my
belief in god simply
also i'm saying that's arbitrary and
everyone is saying oh you know everyone
can agree upon the fact that they see a
child
being hurt or something that they'll
feel that way i can say the majority of
the world agrees upon that there's an
exam
there's a supernatural existence but i
mean that number isn't fluctuating and
and which god and how
consistent though in terms of
supernaturalism it's been very
consistent there's so much that people
believe
that have believed the majority have
believed in in the past as well like
that
i don't i mean i mean again when you say
god i mean even
that definition is not a consistent
definition and it's not a consistent
understanding of
what god is and how he or she should be
worshipped
exactly the abrahamic religions are only
really not that far away from each other
when all these kind of prophets
you know they're also in this sort of
similar region as well where all these
prophets kind of
arose from and had very similar ideas
and you know kind of um
all these kind of prophecies and
everything that happened it's
it's within i mean i can't remember how
many years now but i had it written down
somewhere it's it's not a huge kind of
distance between
that time and what what
you know if if it is there's so many
there's so many things we can go into
that it'll take literally hours and
hours what i'm trying to say is that if
you
like i said go back to the discussion if
you're going to
justify particular moral
or moral structures moral theories or
particular
uh ethical decisions on the basis of the
consensus or natural consensus of
mankind then you likewise have to give
the same credence
to religious thought in general not
simply
the the sort of naturalistic
explanations that you've been given
so you're saying le i just i don't fully
understand but is this what you're
saying that because
we're saying the majority of people have
human instincts and
would naturally want to do the right
thing you're saying well majority people
believe in god therefore
it should be true the people that
naturally naturally the majority of
people it's a normative thing
psychologically
people believe in the supernatural i
don't know about that without being
without being taught
that's been actually without being
taught but hang on so so
just just to on that point at one point
even now at one point in time the vast
majority of human beings believe jesus
is the son of god
and believed in multiple gods but just
on the point of the son of god because
i believe the world is mostly christian
or if you
go back 100 years when it was mostly
christian the vast majority of human
beings
thought it was natural or logical to
believe that jesus was the son of god
but that's something that you would
disagree with
i would say they've naturally believed
it i believe they naturally believe well
i mean
that's how they do i believe that this
particular
yeah so i mean naturally that is the
more you have to understand that their
belief in jesus was contingent upon
natural inclination towards god
okay that's fine but i'm trying to say
is then the the most
uh the you say uh believing god is not
or without vast majority of human beings
believe it's natural
okay but when you get down to the
nitty-gritty when you actually get down
to the details
oh okay we believe in a god that is son
of god trinity whatever
but then you would say hang on a second
that's the wrong god that's not the
right god i was talking about and then
you get into the
endless theological debates which
actually don't sound like because i can
do the same thing to you
i can say there are but the difference
is my claim is not supernatural
i don't know that's fine but you but
you're saying you're saying okay so
let's agree that it's all natural but
then you have all these details
i can do the same thing for you there
are so many different moral theories and
political theories
so i could say that now yours is
nonsense you can
well i'm not going to do that no but
what i'm trying to say
so just just to give my perspective on
this i
do not uh have the same level of
sort of certainty in that my moral is
god sealed approved right whatever it is
and i'm not making a supernatural claim
i'm doing my best to be as cautious as
possible when we're making a claim
to refer to evidence science of reason
as opposed to saying
this book said x therefore it's true
that
it's a very different methodology when
you get down to it one is very much more
cautious and skeptical whereas the other
one is saying
god said x therefore it's true and i
think that is a massive
leap in uh thinking or logic which
requires
much more evidence and uh reason which i
i don't think a lot of
religions have provided because they say
well god said it and you said it's four
i'm not trying to attack you but he said
god god can do anything so he can do it
god
god wants this so because he said that a
lot of my family would say things like
that to me when they were kind of trying
to get back
because god said so yeah i mean you're
someone who you know
is very vigorous when it comes to sort
of thinking and intellectual thought
so i would have thought just saying god
said so i mean that's not much of an
answer it's like for example
uh you know alana's best okay
he does but it doesn't solve anything it
does something
i think that's a very crude
representation of what i said
that was a good representation i
understand but the point i'm trying to
say is i said i said very clearly that
if god is capable if you believe that
god is capable
of doing certain things and a particular
claim within that religious tradition
should not be
you know surprising to you right like
that that's not
that's a very different thing to say
well god just said it so accept it you
know that's not
that's not really the same thing and
likewise i just want to point out
something here
that i think that uh you claiming that
our standards are different
maybe they are in terms of how we
express them but i don't think that you
follow the very standard that you're
that you're trying to apply to my
religious beliefs in terms of your moral
and other prescriptions that you have
with regard to the world like the way
that you see the world that you perceive
it
in terms of morality in terms of values
your your ideas about free speech and
things like that
none of this operates by any sort of
scientific standard
none of it i i i don't understand so
like it just doesn't like but what does
that matter though
it doesn't matter if you're trying to be
consistent with what you're asking for
no but um i'm saying if me believing in
free speech how is that
not scientific or science why do you
believe in it
well okay no no
in fact it doesn't because some people
say may say some really nasty things
against me but if i believe in free
speech i have to accept what they have
to say why do you believe it then
okay so i believe it because if we are
ever going to get close to the truth
whatever that is
the only way we can get there is to have
the most
open level of inquiry into all sorts of
uh domains of
uh all sorts of fields of knowledge as
possible that means we have to
be able to ask any question we have to
say be able to say anything
and that that means most of the time we
might get things wrong in fact most time
of human history and even now
we still get things wrong but hopefully
the more open that discussion is
the closer we will get to whatever the
truth is whatever it is whatever it
looks like
we're getting inching closer and closer
to the truth the moment you say
you can't ask this question you can't
say x you can't
question the authority of this person or
this state or this king
then you are sort of uh closing that
door
to that possible truth or getting closer
to that truth
so it actually has a very logical or
reasoned
uh foundation it's very practical
it's pragmatic i mean it's the only way
we can get to the truth whatever that is
here's okay say that i don't actually
agree with that entirely i'll express
why in a minute but
um first off that's there nothing you
said was
had any sort of scientific verification
um so that's my one problem
and then the second problem that i have
is that i don't think that's entirely
true so let me give you a counter
example just
just entertain the thought for a moment
sure okay imagine
that all the people who deny evolution
in the united states
get power and then decide you know what
we want to teach our kids that evolution
isn't true
okay and uh we want to have debates
with people who believe in evolution
right but it's sort of this unfair
platform so they can they can talk all
they want
right but we want to be able to spread
all our nonsense everywhere
you know until everyone's affected now
and imagine all the majority of the
society then becomes convinced by those
arguments
that these people that evolution is not
true or that flat earth is right
okay because you see a lot of that
online by the way a lot of people are
starting to buy into all these
conspiracy theories because of all this
openness of information and quote
unquote free speech we're not we're not
demarcating between what is fact
and what is not right so imagine that
the people who are wrong
about a lot of these scientific issues
because there's free speech end up
convincing the rest of society
so what are you going to say then i mean
because by the way in the united states
you're not allowed to teach creationism
in schools
yeah so if that's opposed to free speech
if so you're saying if they want to do
that that's fine
if i'm in the united states and everyone
is saying even illusion is wrong
my position is i should be allowed to
object to that that's that's what i'm
saying
okay but what if but what if they like
okay right now in the us they're saying
that
you're not allowed to to to teach
creation it's not a real science
it's not fact it's it's false yeah okay
so
is that opposed to free speech
are you asking me if i would ass is it
opposed to free speech that the united
states is banning
the teaching of creationism in schools
well completely why no
no no i'm asking you have they said that
you can't teach
like creationism it's actually been
banned in a lot of places you're like
you're not you're like okay
that's fine i've got no problem with
saying that's wrong
i mean that's because for me here's the
thing that i have a problem with
like say academic institutions had this
sort of understanding that
you're saying about how free speech
leads to all of these things and then we
just let random people come into the
school
and teach whatever the hell they want oh
okay i think that's a huge issue
okay so the difference between okay so
so for example uh
let you know you're muslim you're part
of the keane institute
if i were to come into your office and
say i think you should teach
uh the earth is flat or for example it's
okay to have gay sex
now you could say no that's not what i
believe and i you know that's your
personal and private institution which
you can say i
stand for x y and z i want to promote
these values
i don't have i i can say you're wrong
but i can't force you
to say you have to teach this if it's a
private institution they can do what
they can
preach evolution is not true or whatever
i don't really care but the point is
that there should always be people
allowed to say the opposite and not be
punished for it that's what i'm saying
okay so
okay so my sorry i just want to make
sure that so only the private
institution
is allowed to have a so in the public
institution where we're trying to teach
kids
for example what the facts are you're
saying that it's disallowed for example
food for
somebody random just come in and say hey
professor
guy um you're wrong we should also have
the same amount of time
to teach our understanding of science to
these kids
but then that's that's not the thing i
think that's
because it will get to confirm which
religion are they going to go with are
they going to be i don't know
i'm not really sure what uh the question
is i'm not trying to dodge i
really don't understand let me clarify
okay what i'm trying to say is that
you're saying that
we need free speech practically speaking
in order so that we can
discuss open ideas with each other and
come to the truth yeah right
okay but what if you've already
determined what the truth is and you
don't want some stupid conspiracy
theorists taking the floor
oh great that's great the best way to
derail or to disprove them is to
actually
speak to them and show them the facts oh
is that the case because i think you're
putting a lot too much confidence in the
majority of the population here
i mean there are people who are easily
convinced about flat earth even though
okay
like they do not care no i don't
understand what you're saying anytime
you say okay now i've got a bit
understanding
so i'm not saying free speech
is perfect i'm saying it's from what
human beings have tried it's the best
way it's the best mechanism to ensure
that there was all that you can
challenge the authority of scientific
authority religious authority political
authority whatever authority
is the best way to challenge it's that
safety mechanism that safety valve i'm
not saying
you know there's many times like we
tomorrow we could we could
be believing something today that is
quote unquote scientific truth
but actually maybe it's not but the best
the best and only way to challenge that
is to have free speech
if you don't have that mechanism you'll
never get there so i'm saying you know
it's i'm not saying it's perfect and
that the moment we say free speech
exists everyone's going to believe in
the truth whatever the truth is
i'm saying it's the best and only
mechanism to ensure that we can
reach there eventually
deal with people you don't like kill the
people you don't like kill the people
oh okay okay yes that is one way of
doing it but that's not a very uh
why don't you do it i'm not i'm not
entertaining that idea
i know i know but it's not a very
sustainable way i mean one day you're
kidding them tomorrow
why not apparently according to some of
the people in your chat
islamic civilization lasted 1400 years
doing just that
that's that's a good point actually that
they they went around
killing people so i'm just i'm not
saying i actually believe that that's
the history
okay i'm trying to use the arguments
here you know what we're proposing we're
looking for a moral standard
okay this is why we're discussing this
right i'm trying to verify your moral
standard now you came at me first by
suggesting that free speech
is probably the best practical means to
reaching the truth and in many ways i
actually
agree with that from a different
perspective from the scientific one that
you
have advanced um however there are other
people who can come along and say for
practical reasons that it's better to
just slaughter everyone i don't like
and is that your alternative to free
speech
no that's not my alternative so what is
your alternative
i don't know what what do you mean
alternative because you're obviously not
you're not keen on on
free speech clearly well i didn't say
that so do you believe in it then
i believe in it yeah i believe free
speech is is a good thing
so what why is it you disagreed yeah
because i i feel like maybe you're
agreeing with me
i'm disagreeing with your standards of
validating or rationalizing a particular
so okay so you told me how would you
validate yeah
i would be having a rational discussion
i think that what the way that we're
discussing right now without having to
refer to any sort of science
is a is a good way of doing it that's
why we're having this discussion right
now
we're not looking without any evidence
is a good way of doing it what do you
mean by evidence
no i'm just trying to understand what
you what do you mean okay so for example
so for people who are not aware of my
field
i'm sure video you are like i'm i i
study philosophy for six years
okay so for us it's like not everything
that we talked about and how we verified
things were based on
science like there was no way to do that
you can't like the majority of things
that humans
believe that the way that we function in
society is not based on that standard
that's what i'm trying to get across
like a lot of things that you object to
even in respect to islam in a moral
sense
has no real scientific standing and
that's fine
it's okay like do you understand what
i'm trying to say like it's fine
yeah but that i'm still a bit confused
though i don't know what that takes away
from speech
free speech i mean you can say whatever
you want but you are you don't want
other people to use science
no i mean the reason no the discussion
started with
how do we validate our particular
viewpoints
and then free speech was brought up as
an example okay
that was the reason i'm not i'm not
talking about whether i like free speech
i'm challenging your perspective on why
you're validating free speech
on the basis of the standard that you
have promoted
the that we need some sort of scientific
standard in order to to believe
rationally in certain things like that
doesn't make any sense to me
i don't think that's true i think we can
come to beliefs without having to
rely on science all the time i think
sometimes we come to beliefs based on
coherent
like the coherency of that particular
viewpoint it's practicality in many
respects as well
and uh you know just just other things
we don't we don't have to look at
science all the time to come to these
conclusions
it doesn't matter i'm okay with that by
the way i'm
personally okay with that and i think we
probably have different viewpoints on
that but i think that's okay
it's it's it's not so much that i don't
think that's what we're arguing against
though i think that's kind of
something off topic yeah that's like
something totally different
from my perspective because yeah it's so
it's so hard to get it into words but
what we're talking about is free speech
and why it's good and what you're
talking about is
what you should back up to do to
for your free speech well you need to
back it up with but
i don't really care what you back up
with a free speech ultimately if you're
if you're
putting a viewpoint across and this is
my this is my viewpoint this is why i
believe it
then whatever like you can be like i
believe in the boogie monster because
of whatever like that doesn't bother me
it's just about ultimately not stopping
other people from believing
whatever they want to believe and what i
don't know i didn't hear all of your
discussion about free speech earlier but
ultimately
muslims don't generally the ones i know
anyway
don't like the kind of aspect of
discussing
islam in in detail i mean you're very
good for kind of having a discussion
with us but a lot of muslims don't want
to ultimately because they don't want
that
any criticism or well yeah i think it's
a problem because the thing is that
you see from my understanding of the
islamic tradition as well
and you can disagree with me if you wish
but there we in our past
when it was so-called more barbaric more
muslim scholars were more open to having
these sort of discussions than people
are today
i'm not even joking like they they had
open debates they had
they wrote treatises against each other
you know what i mean like nowadays you
can't even like
you're wrong and then people get really
angry and it's just like
you know even even like little issues
about sex for example
like you know such a big taboo thing and
like daisy yeah
it's like scholars wrote volumes about
how like how to have sex
i'm not even joking it's like nowadays
it's like
you can't even talk about it without the
auntie at next door but like shut up
there's actually a lot about sex in
islam
a lot and one of the one of the things
that
i personally really you know when i was
kind of having doubts
one of the things that kept coming back
and i kept trying to find answers for
were the sex slaves that was just
something i couldn't
like it just didn't fly six to six
slaves okay yeah
yeah that's what we do on this channel
all right no but but i do i don't
understand that like there were so many
so many
i mean they'll take you literally days
for us to go into like so many reasons
why
i left them but one of them was that i
was like how is this okay
it's in the quran it's because i went
through a phase where i was like oh it's
hadith maybe hadiths are not that legit
i'll go with the quran but this is like
in the quran so i was like i couldn't
even run away from it
but like the what the right hand
possesses like these women
you could just sleep with them what do
you think about that i'd be really
interested to know you want to ask
okay well i will tell you that
all right you should read an article
document this is this is what you
believe so
ultimately yeah like this is going to be
a larger discussion too now and i'm just
being frank with you like i'm
it's already been two hours okay so uh
we don't want to go for good healing i
want to know my beliefs on the subject
okay if you really want to know what i
think about it right there is an actual
article you can see my views
on the subject matter so this is
something you've spoken about well i
haven't spoken about
personally yet though i assisted one of
the other professors and scholars in
this respect
for writing this article and thinking
okay anyway so like i said on our
website yet keen institute we have it's
an article on the subject matter okay
if you want to know my views you can go
there
can i ask you one more question that's
completely different though i don't know
if you want to
sorry i just you're a very popular man i
just remembered something that i thought
about there were so many questions i had
when i was watching you earlier
and one of them was when you were
talking about the nine-year-old so
believe has always as
when we were both muslims he always was
like she wasn't nine years old
and i do think she was nine years old
um there's talk about her and you were
like oh well they developed
and i like that idea that that's a nice
way because it's horrible to think that
she was nine and twelve
times you're completely you're
completely okay
within the contemporary period that's
fine but no but she had
she had dolls and she was playing with
dolls don't you not know about the
narrative of how she had brought dolls
to the pockets house
and then also she and she would play
with them and he'd let her play with
them and then you know he wouldn't force
anything upon her
and then he didn't actually have sex
with her until
he would masturbate on her and that that
description is very clear of how he
would masturbate between her thighs
rather than rather than because she was
so young
and okay sorry as for the thigh thing
that's that's
that's that's invalid but let me but i
will i will back your opinion about it
she was older i feel like muslims would
be like that one's gonna know
i'm sorry walid my apologies uh your
opinion that she was older is actually
not appropriate in terms of like the
hadith evidence and stuff there's no
validity behind your position i'm sorry
but
i am i am in most cases wrong anyway so
i'm completely okay with being
there there's no there's no validity
behind it whatsoever in terms of
scholarly tradition that's fine opinion
just came about like muslims just like
to
believe that i think the past hundred
years that was the only that was the
only reason it ever came up
to that muslims and scholars all thought
she was nine
and they all used evidence so she is
correct in this respect
and uh however she's correct she's gonna
say she's correct in most respects
anyway so i'll just have to take it on
the chin in terms
in terms of the the thyme thing though
that there's no there's no there's no
hadith
validity behind that at all that was a
uh that's also a later review
uh i'm just trying to be fair here and i
understand the doll hadith is also true
uh that is also true and uh and okay
before we go on even further sorry
so wednesday i actually am personally
authoring an article about this where i
explained my argument in 27 pages
so you can please read that as well when
it comes out i will and then we should
have part two after i've read the two
things
but i want to tell you before we
conclude any of this because i don't
know if i don't want to look at the
comments anymore too many idiots
uh so so um
you know okay so i'm sorry
i'm not blaming you necessarily i'm just
saying that you do have a lot of
troglodytes in the chat room
so so um i have enjoyed talking to you
guys and i
thank you so much for being fortunate no
listen listen uh uh uh
man honestly i wanna i wanna give a
massive shout out to yourself you uh
absolute star coming on oh
it's been three how many hours has been
almost three you know
i think it's three now that's that's
amazing so we've gone for an absolute
marathon
uh on this um so i wanna i genuinely
wanna thank you and
we've had such an open uh discussion i i
haven't felt like i've had to censor
myself or whatever it is or whatever and
and i hope there's no if i said
something wrong
i know i hope that we just i didn't be
frank with you guys i want to discuss
these things more in the future but i
feel like that we should dedicate like a
video per topic
yeah yeah that's a good idea because
that would make it a lot better for us
because i don't
i'm gonna be frank with you i do not
like sort of the mcdonald's
buff you know buffet people just sort of
throwing memes out there
if you really want to comprehend a
subject and you want to
oppose it or support it you should steal
man it as much as possible
in the most comprehensive way because i
don't like these crude characters of
either of our beliefs you know i don't
understand
we will also crudely you know depict you
guys
or your beliefs in a specific manner i'm
sure you don't appreciate it either
likewise i don't like that
so so yeah i i think what you said is
put on uh i
if i have a your views i
i certainly wasn't intentional from my
point of view uh
and i apologize if i have i want to give
a massive shout out to yourself i would
love
love love to do a part two i've really
enjoyed this what we should do then
is maybe have we obviously talk behind
the scenes set
topics and then you can bring your
prepared documents yeah yeah
you refer to them a lot so maybe have
them have we could actually
because when you release one of them you
could actually focus it on
that article if you want yeah and then
discussions there are things that i
really want to talk about like in terms
of
terrorism and stuff too there's a lot of
myths that are out there
you know um regarding like why muslims
behave the way they're doing things and
i think it's appropriate to get that
away if we really want to have
discussions
too and i appreciate that you guys
actually want me to do this because
i've told you 100 times before that i've
i'm sorry hundreds of times before when
i've tried to interact with people
or even a lot of other ex-muslims like
they won't even let me
like cite the academic evidence sure
oh no we want evidence for sure so we're
talking about science and evidence we're
waiting we've been waiting for everybody
and maybe we can also talk about you
know the standards of epistemology
because um
i don't know i know we had very brief
discussion on that but you know i have a
very
holistic way of looking at things in my
opinion like i don't just say we need
science for this
all the time and sometimes over here i
do believe that you know pragmatic
arguments work very well and i think
that there are other ways of verifying
our beliefs
and i think if we come to that
conclusion then we'd be much more
productive conversation as well that was
what i was trying to interact with you
guys i was trying to get you guys to
like
you know produce your justifications
beyond that because i wanted to prove a
point
and i wasn't trying to like own you or
anything i just wanted you guys no no no
no
no no what i think we have to do is
obviously not
take it personally i think we're both
sides i think we've basically done that
and i
i know i can be quite harsh when i speak
so it's because i it's because of my end
i work in sales so sometimes i know i
can be quite hard when i speak to people
but but um but
yeah it's it's like you know i'm just
kind of
doing it i didn't take it i didn't take
it wrong at all
you should see the people i deal with on
a daily basis like you're that's nothing
like it's like there are people in the
comment section right now calling me all
sorts of worlds
oh yeah oh yeah we we get it too i mean
oh yeah
i'm used to it so much i just don't care
so
absolutely so listen uh just to finish
off because i know we've taken so much
your time and i really appreciate it
uh i want us to give a massive shout out
to the live man check out his channel
check out his story really good story i
really enjoyed it
massive thank you for coming on the show
real real real pleasure i've just got
one last question
uh this which might it's not it's not
like a theological question it's just
more of a sort of quick question
um this might annoy you but uh i've been
told to ask this so apologies beforehand
um someone has said uh gets his cronies
from time to time and challenge me for a
chat but every time i agree i never hear
back
are you ready for a chat with me or are
you still nervous that's from hara
sultan
oh oh what's that har sultan um
let me let me be frank with you just
like i'm frank with your friends
okay get the proper education first
before you come after me
wow oh my god the first time we've had
like beef on our channel get the proper
education before you come after me and
don't try to talk down to me again
because you are
a peasant done wow
i think when we're going to comment
and if you and if you get to talk to me
that's a privilege
okay end of discussion you guys are my
friends as far as i'm concerned so i
will speak with you but this guy's a
[__] well um
hara satan uh you heard it there um
well there's not much more i can say on
that issue um
so um any any last words
no i just want to thank you again and i
appreciate it and uh like i said um
i respect you guys for respecting me and
i respect you guys for being open having
an
honest and sincere discussion and i
apologize for being a little rude at
times with some of the others but
you have to understand that i have to
demarcate
no worries thank you so much you've been
so great and i loved
loved it speaking to you again at some
point and uh keep doing the saturn keep
keep doing it i think it's great
i will do my best but it's probably not
going to be at your level okay
all right man all right listen thank you
so much guys in the comment section
thank you so much i'm sorry i couldn't
get through all the questions there's
too many questions too little time uh
but i want to thank you guys
and we will hopefully do this again i
i've already enjoyed it and i hope you
guys are
you guys have as well thank you from why
for coming in
and uh showing me how it's done i'm
still learning i'm still learning
uh thank you very much harris said he's
a peasant yes you are a president you're
a [__] as well
so guys stay safe be happy and we will
see you
next time i hope to answer the question
there you go there you go thank you guys
cheers